[Musique]
afin de ballon
il a déjà un petit cadeau il a plu la
calotte à celle-ci
d'ailleurs j'ai vu j'ai regardé à la
télé quand il
est arrivé tellement de Mistral
enfin le devais pas sinon je crois qu'il
est arrivé à l'aéroport
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la mise au point
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il peut y aller avec la robe là
ah
oui c'est bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il a des lunettes qu'on regarde
l'appareil photo
c'est l'objectif de la
allez à plus
tard
moi je vais le voir c'est tout ce qui
est
[Musique]
c'est pas encore là attends
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il est 15h48 dans les studios du Figaro
15h48 ici sur le Prado à Marseille c'est
la plus populaire la plus
impressionnante étape de ce voyage du
pape François à Marseille en France vous
avez pu le suivre en direct depuis ce
matin et depuis le début de l'après-midi
François descend le Prado les tweets les
messages afflux pour signaler les
présences aux abords et dans le stade
Vélodrome et c'est là qu'on retrouve
tout de suite Timothée d'Hélène Timothée
c'est tout Marseille qui s'est donné
rendez-vous au Prado et au voleur Drôme
[Applaudissements]
Marseille qui s'est donné rendez-vous
cet après-midi au stade Vélodrome le
stade Vélodrome une ambiance vient de
monter d'un cran vous l'entendez
derrière moi ces applaudissements et une
très nourri qui sont en train vraiment
de monter d'un cran et puis cette cette
eau là depuis quelques minutes c'est
trop là dans le stade au moment qui a
été lancé au moment où le pape François
la silhouette du pape François est
apparue à l'écran géant du stade
Vélodrome le stade Vélodrome qui est
plein comme un oeuvre cet après-midi
certains fidèles sont positionnés dans
les gradins d'autres sont positionnés
sur la pelouse sur le terre-plein qui a
été positionné pardon exprès vous le
voyez derrière moi cette cette tribune
qui évite ça c'est la seule tribune du
stade qui est vide et c'est prévu par
l'organisation parce que c'est l'endroit
où le pape François va célébrer cette
messe avec l'hôtel que vous distinguez
peut-être juste derrière moi
alors Timothée il paraît que Gad Elmaleh
a été sollicité en chauffeur de stade
est-ce que vous étiez présent
oui je vous confirme Vincent parce que
c'est vrai que les fidèles sont arrivés
ici écrit depuis longtemps cela fait
deux bonnes heures que nous avons aperçu
les premières fils les premières queues
qui attendaient et bien aux abords du
stade pour pouvoir pénétrer les fidèles
qui sont très nombreux et qu'il a fallu
faire patienter et c'est donc Gad
Elmaleh qui s'y est collé avec avec une
petite intervention assez courte une
dizaine de minutes à peine il a parlé
notamment de l'importance que
représentée pour vous le vivre ensemble
il a expliqué que c'était important pour
lui d'être présent aujourd'hui que cela
avait du sens à ses yeux il n'y a pas eu
que Gad Elmaleh il y a également eu le
groupe de louange glorieux s'il y a
également eu pardon Mehdi Jadid le
comédien et puis la la chanteuse de
Ghost de gospel également Dana Joe voilà
donc une ambiance de fête une ambiance
qui est en train de de monter ici ou les
60 000 fidèles présents attendent
désormais avec impatience l'arrivée du
sans père et effectivement c'est arrivé
on va la suivre en direct avec vous
Timothée avec vous chers internautes qui
nous rejoignent à la fois sur le site du
Figaro merci beaucoup de votre de
fidélité et également sur la page
Youtube du Figaro vous commentez vous
nous donnez vos questions vos réactions
les partages ici avec nos invités en
plateau bonjour Cédric burgien bonjour
vous êtes vice doyen de la Faculté de
Droit canonique institut catholique de
Paris bien connu des médias et on va
vous allez nous aider un petit peu être
le tchatcheron comme on dit à Rome dans
cette célébration un peu hors norme
pour comprendre un peu les différentes
étapes de la messe ce sera un peu notre
notre cérémonière et on reviendra
également sur l'actualité de l'église et
l'impact de ce voyage Philippe Fontana
bonjour vous êtes avocat et auteur de la
vérité sur le droit d'asile c'est aux
éditions de l'Observatoire vous êtes
spécialisés notamment sur le sur le
droit de l'asile et on reviendra avec
vous sur à la fois ce qui s'est dit et
sur qui va se dire au Vélodrome avec une
autre spécialiste du droit d'asile
Elisabeth betandelègue en tant que
diplomate et également magistrate juge à
ses sœurs à la Cour nationale du droit
d'asile et vous avez été auparavant
ambassadrice de France auprès de siège
les internautes du Figaro le savent
puisque ils ont le plaisir de vous
entendre et d'avoir vos commentaires vos
analyses vos lumières vos éclairages
depuis le début de cette visite qui a
donc débuté il y a après-midi père
Cédric Burda la Burga pardon là ce sera
pas les dieux du stade mais c'est un
stade qui est dédié à Dieu aujourd'hui
c'est un stade qui est dédié à Dieu qui
est plein moi je suis frappé de voir
l'enthousiasme que suicide cette
rencontre avec le Pape François et le
monde que cela déplace et donc cela
montre que la parole du pape est
attendue et attendu par un certain
nombre de milliers de personnes sur des
sujets aussi cruciaux que l'IM mais
aussi d'autres sujets sur les sujets de
la foi évidemment et puis ce matin je
note que le pape François a eu des
paroles extrêmement fortes devant le
président Macron sur des sujets aussi
graves que le tanasie ou l'avortement et
donc on voit bien que le message du pape
François est là pour bousculer les
consciences à une époque où on a
peut-être tendance à s'endormir sur un
certain nombre de sujets et pas que sur
l'immigration vous avez été
surpris par ces paroles sur
l'immigration sur la vie sur
l'immigration sur l'avortement et sur le
pas nécessairement surpris parce que je
sais que le pape François est attentif
aussi à ces sujets j'ai été surpris
qu'elle soit aussi forte et devant le
gouvernement français
on sait que enfin on a cru comprendre
que le gouvernement français avait
décalé la loi sur l'euthanasie à cause
de la venue du Saint Père et bien le
Saint Père envoie un message fort et il
veut pas simplement dire des choses qui
nous plaisir il est là aussi vraiment
comme je le disais auparavant pour
bousculer les consciences et que ce soit
les fidèles catholiques à qui sont
message ne plaît pas nécessairement
toujours d'ailleurs que ce soit les
fidèles catholiques ou les gouvernements
politiques le pape François disent qu'il
a dit et je trouve que c'est un homme
qui a beaucoup de courage et beaucoup de
force dans sa Parole et on a vraiment un
exemple à tiré de tout cela en tout cas
c'est ce qu'il avait espéré ce qu'il a
déclaré dans l'avion en allant en
standard à Marseille puisque il disait
selon le confrères qui étaient présents
avec lui dans le vol d'Ital Airways
qu'il espérait avoir le courage de dire
tout ce qu'il voulait dire à Marseille
Philippe Fontana est-ce que vous avez
d'abord écouté et qu'est-ce que vous
avez qu'est-ce qui vous a frappé dans
tout ce qui a été dit jusqu'à présent
j'ai écouté avec beaucoup d'attention la
parole du Saint Père j'espère qu'à la
messe nous aura un message plus pastoral
que politique car pour l'instant entendu
un message de culpabilisation envers
l'Occident ce qui m'a beaucoup frappé ce
sont deux choses d'une part quand ce
jeune homme a eu les Actes des Apôtres
et il s'est arrêté au moment où Paul
avait fait aller faire naufrage il n'a
pas lu les phrases suivantes et les
phrases suivantes c'est Paul et Luc
puisque vous savez que c'est Luc le
rédacteur qui dit nous avons été reçus
avec une humanité peu ordinaire moi ce
que je veux dire au peuple François
c'est que l'Europe reçoit les migrants
avec une humanité peu ordinaire et que
ces migrants aimeraient bien une telle
humanité de la part d'autres continents
dans lequel il migre ça c'est la
première des choses donc le message
culpabilisateur du pape François à un
moment me laisse quoi la deuxième chose
que j'ai retenue toujours dans cet
aspect très politique du pape François
c'est sa rencontre avec SOS Méditerranée
les organisateurs sans doute épiscopats
avaient fait avaient pris grand soin de
mettre des personnes au premier rang
avec des T-Shirts ciglés et SOS
Méditerranée en gros le pape s'est
approché d'eux et le radis c'est avec
plaisir que je rencontre ceux qui
partent en mer sauver des migrants alors
effectivement qui était juste à côté oui
bon mais qu'importe la SNCF
pardon se baladant en Méditerranée pour
être comme le dit Frontex les taxis des
migrants c'est-à-dire le rôle que joue
SOS Méditerranée donc vous voyez que le
Pape a un message extrêmement politique
ce qui est fait évidemment pour déplaire
un nombre de catholiques français qui
n'aiment pas que le pape Diane un
message politique et qui reste sur un
message pastoral il est vrai que le pape
part sur cette tragédie que nous
rencontrons en Méditerranée de 27000
personnes qui sont mortes et dix
dernières années mais sa réaction ce qui
nous propose c'est la politique il dit
que il souhaiterait qu'il y ait plus de
migrants qui viennent légalement sur le
territoire or on le sait et ça vous fera
vous avez entendu
sur le territoire oui il a dit qu'il
fallait faire venir plus de migrants de
façon légale et régulière la vraie
difficulté c'est que les millions de
personnes
en tout cas c'est la retranscription que
j'ai lu dans votre journal les millions
et les millions de personnes qui sont
venues depuis 10 ans sur le sol européen
sont venus en faisant semblant de
demander la cils alors que pour la plus
grande majorité d'entre elles se sont
des demandeurs les économiques se sont
des migrants économiques donc vous voyez
que la parole du pape risque de
s'ébrécher lorsqu'il fait de la
politique et lorsqu'une délivent pas un
message seulement pastoral et je
voudrais terminer quand il s'adresse à
la ville de Marseille où il y a 88
personnes et je n'ai pas entendu
peut-être qu'il a dit il n'a pas parlé
la tragédie qui ce qui est en train de
faire souffrir l'harmonie dans son
territoire le plus ancien ça ce sont des
personnes déplacées et j'espère qu'il va
en parler pendant l'homélie et qui va
demander à l'Europe non pas d'accueillir
plus de grands parlant des institutions
européennes mais qui va demander aux
institutions européennes de cesser tout
pétrolier avec un pays qui persécute des
populations on va on va le voir la
réponse ensuite d'elisabethon de l'aigle
comme vous le disiez hier les propos
feront polémiques et sans doute débat on
est justement pendant on regarde donc
l'arrivée du pape François à au stade
Vélodrome à Marseille père Cédric
burguin un pape dans un stade c'est la
France qui est à l'origine de ce genre
de de
d'accueil c'était le Parc des Princes
Jean-Paul II en 1980 si vous me
permettez c'est pas même si c'est une
sorte de nouveauté qu'un Pape célèbre
une messe dans un stade les grands
rassemblements pontificaux on y est
habitué au Portugal il y a trois soucis
semaine le Pape a célébré la messe
devant un million virgule cinq personnes
les JMJ de Rome c'était sur un grand
stade 2 millions de personnes et en fait
la parité de Paris 1 million de
personnes à Paris en 97 la papauté est
habituée à ce genre de grand
rassemblement et le fait que ça soit
dans un ce stade n'est pas la question
la plus essentielle me semble-t-il c'est
le fait qu'une personne de cet âge avec
un message aussi fort rassemble autant
de personnes cet été vous connaissez
beaucoup de stars au monde qui
réunissent 1,5 millions de personnes pas
grand monde et donc quand on nous dit
que l'Église son message n'est pas
audible est à bout de souffle etc on
voit une vraie dimension de force et la
parole d'un homme qui est attendu par
toute cette population pour moi c'est ça
qui est le plus important est-ce que
justement quand on voit ces images et
cet accueil effectivement
attendu mais toujours assez
impressionnant au sein du Vélodrome à
Marseille
est-ce que d'un point de vue
géopolitique justement on n'est pas au
cœur là aussi une forme de soft power du
Saint-Siège et du Vatican bien sûr le
Pape est une personnalité spirituelle
d'influence bien évidemment d'ailleurs
qu'est-ce que c'est que les armes du
pont d'un pape c'est la parole c'est la
parole sa parole la parole des évangiles
et la parole de tous ceux qui portent
cette parole de Parlement bien
évidemment et vous avez remarqué mais ça
c'est aussi l'air du temps je veux dire
que le pape est aussi un pape 2.0 si je
peux dire parce que il est présent il
est présent sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est les actions que qu'il mène sont
relayées je veux dire il y a une vraie
un oeuvre écosystème si je puis dire de
communication qui empruntent aujourd'hui
les moyens les moyens complètement
modernes ça aussi c'est une c'est
incroyable le stade rempli à rabord
comme on dit à Marseille et c'est le cas
puisque là en plus on le savait depuis
quelques temps parce que il y avait des
billets pour pour le stade et que les 50
que les 57000 billets qui ont été mis à
l'occasion ou tout c'était
depuis déjà le mois de mai ou le mois de
juin moi-même avec je suis professeur
dans un séminaire avec les séminaristes
on aurait voulu s'organiser et dès le
mois de mai les trains étaient bondés
réservés le stade Vélodrome rempli et
donc on le savait depuis des mois que
cet événement allait être une réussite
pour le Saint Père et pour l'archevêché
de Marseille et le cardinal à velvin
qu'est-ce que justement vous dites il y
a une attente qu'est-ce que l'Église de
France aujourd'hui à temps de cette de
cette visite
ça dépend ce que vous mettez sous les le
terme d'église de France je vous pose la
question différemment on a entendu
également le Monseigneur de
moulin-beaufort le président de la
Conférence de France ce matin
comment il faut interpréter décoder son
son message et son discours moi je pense
que les chrétiens de France les
catholiques de France attendent d'être
encouragés par le père dans une
situation où il faut le dire l'Église de
France n'est pas en grande forme et donc
le fait que cette visite du pape à
Marseille viennent encourager les
fidèles et pour moi un grand signe
d'espérance par rapport à l'église et
c'est je crois que tant de les fidèles
catholiques qui se sont réunis à
Marseille ou qui vont regarder cette
messe à travers les réseaux puisque il y
a les 60000 personnes du stade mais il y
a tous ceux qui vont regarder cet
après-midi et recevoir le message du
Saint Père pour être fortifié dans leur
foi effectivement il y a également les
internautes du Figaro qui nous regardent
en direct sur le site ainsi que sur
YouTube
salut Jean-Paul alors Jean-Paul est un
internaute fidèle du Figaro et en plus
son nom c'est toujours Jean-Paul II
alors donc c'est aujourd'hui qu'il faut
le saluer et donner son nom intégral
et donc qui nous rejoint vous commentez
vous poser vos questions vous réagissez
à ce que disent nos invités sur la
question effectivement donc Philippe
Fontana disait tout à l'heure ils
avaient de buttant de l'aigle vous vous
êtes également à la Cour nationale de
droit d'asile
il y a un détournement vous observez un
détournement du droit d'asile
aujourd'hui vous êtes je précise que la
Cour nationale du droit d'asile et la
juridiction qui examine les recours des
requérants qui ont été déboutés du droit
d'asile donc nous voilà qui ont été
déboutés par l'ofpraque et l'organisme
administratif et
elle juge on je dirais avec en face
d'elle le requérant à qui on peut poser
des questions bien sûr mais sur la base
dire du corpus juridique national
international évidemment à la convention
à la Convention de Genève et européen
alors
vous regardez les taux les taux de rejet
ils sont extrêmement importants je veux
dire le globalement sous votre contrôle
parce que j'ai pas j'ai pas tous les
chiffres mais globalement
demande d'asile c'est à peu près 20% par
rapport à l'ensemble des demandes
présentées et moi je ne peux vous dire
que de mon expérience dire que
ce puisque nous ces gens avec des
personnes que nous ne connaissons pas
moi je voudrais simplement
faire parler de leur professionnalisme
de leur
récence de responsabilité de leur
éthique et du fait que effectivement je
veux dire quand un rejet était payé et
que rien dans le récit du ou de la
requérante dire ne permet de remettre
d'apporter un éclairage différent de
celui de l'entretien qu'il a déjà et
bien
le rejet confirmé je vois absolument pas
de laxisme bien au contraire
une question
persédrique burghin
question juriste que vous êtes alors
bien sûr on a bien compris que le Pape a
demandé qu'il fallait pas que les
évêques et donc j'imagine le clergé soit
des donneurs de prescription mais enfin
il y a quand même des règles au sein de
l'Église et en particulier sur la valeur
des paroles du pape il y a différents
degrés
Philippe Fontana disait sans doute des
catholiques qui sont en désaccord par
avec certains propos du pape jusqu'où un
catholique peut être en accord et en
désaccord dans quand le pape justement
aborde la question sociale et la
question sociale et politique en fait
dans le discours des papes il y a
toujours différentes niveaux
Magistériels les papes engager le plus
le plus fort degré c'est engager
l'infaillibilité pontificale ce que n'a
pas fait Françoise que n'a pas fait
Benoît XV et ce que n'a pas fait
Jean-Paul II et là on engage
l'infaillibilité pontificale pour des
dogmes extrêmement importants par contre
là qu'on veuille ou non on est obligé
d'y croire si on a des plus exactement
un catholique est tenu de croire aux
différents dogmes qui ont été proclamés
comme tel dernier 1952 de l'Assomption
de la Vierge Marie ensuite vous avez des
discours qui qui découlent véritablement
de la théologie et de la morale auquel
un chrétien est tenu d'adhérer mais ce
que je veux dire par là c'est que dans
le discours
on va le qualifier de politique mais je
pense qu'on met pas nécessairement la
même chose sous le même mot c'est à dire
que moi quand je dis que le Pape a un
discours politique c'est un discours qui
s'occupe du bien de la cité qui n'est
pas un discours politiqueien un pape
c'est normal qu'il est un discours
politique n'importe quel citoyen qui
s'intéresse un peu à la cité dans
laquelle il vit un discours politique et
donc le Pape a un discours politique ce
qui ne me gêne absolument pas comme
n'importe quel personne qui veut avoir
ou qui a une influence de Parlement mais
sur un certain nombre de points de son
discours politique un catholique peut
sembler être en désaccord ou en tout cas
être gêné par son discours ça n'en fait
pas un moins bon catholique sur sur ces
sujets sur ces trois points quand même
qui ont été justement des sorties du
pape François dans le discours de ce
matin immigration ou la parle de la
stérilité de l'assimilation sur
l'euthanasie et sur l'avortement est-ce
que
catholique peut dire sur ces trois
points c'est optionnel le pape pense qui
veut et moi je pense ce que je veux sur
ça ou bien est-ce que il y a un des
trois sur certains points il est il est
il est plus tenu que d'autres mais déjà
je pense qu'il faut nuancer par rapport
à ce qu'on ce que le pape dit sur la
question de l'immigration il me semble
que dans son discours ce matin il a
rappelé qu'il y avait un droit immigré
mais qu'il y avait aussi un droit à ne
pas immigrer est-ce que le pape critique
beaucoup c'est le fait que nous
laissions les migrants mourir en
Méditerranée le pape ne fait pas du
droit à l'immigration un espèce de dogme
catholique auquel on devrait croire ce à
quoi il s'intéresse et là où il veut
bousculer les consciences c'est tous ces
migrants qu'on laisse mourir en
Méditerranée ou dans les différents
bateaux et donc là dessus n'importe quel
chrétien peut considérer que laisser
mourir quelqu'un et contraire à la
volonté de Dieu sur notre humanité les
responsables politiques sont dans les
tribunes également on vient de les voir
notamment en Gérald Darmanin Christine
Lagarde
entrepreneurs de la Banque centrale
européenne et ainsi que les responsables
de la région sud
renomméselier le maire de Marseille
Benoît Payen et Lionel Macron et
accueilli par Brigitte Macron accueilli
par Renaud Muselier Martine vassal
président du conseil départemental à
côté ce droit à ne pas immigrer a été
redit effectivement ce matin
on peut vous ne Fontana on peut pas ne
pas faire comme si le pape n'avait pas
dit évidemment d'abord je voudrais
rebondir sur les chiffres donnés par ma
voisine effectivement la CNDA
n'accueille que 20% des recours mais
avec l'ofra ça fait un peu plus de 40%
des demandeurs d'asile qui l'obtiennent
en France et la jurisprudence de la CNDA
est extrêmement extensive puisqu'elle
accorde l'Asie pour une personne qui est
asservie domestiquement dire une jeune
Guinéenne qui va en Tunisie
qui souffrent dans une famille d'accueil
qui revient dans son pays et qui part en
France elle aura l'asile qui est accordé
par la Senia et c'est extrêmement c'est
un exemple que vous donnez moi j'ai
jamais vécu ce type de juillet 2020 de
mémoire mais c'est un exemple posé que
je vous donne les enfants
c'est pour ça que j'ai écrit un livre
pour faire comprendre à nos concitoyens
comment l'asile était donnée de plus en
plus généreusement dans notre pays ce
qu'il faut savoir aussi c'est que toute
personne même qui vit dans un état
démocratique qui fait partie du nethi ou
les jeunes filles se font exciser a le
droit d'asile en France vous voyez c'est
encore essentiel gérance quand vous me
parlez de ce que dit le Pape sur la
Méditerranée mais évidemment que moi le
premier c'est ce que je parle
d'interventions
ça ne peut pas être un cimetière et
d'ailleurs le problème et d'ailleurs je
vais vous dire dans le mystère de la
révélation que ça soit chez nos frères
aînés de la il y a toujours eu cette
migration avrain mais parti ce qui a
rappelé le papier
d'Irak est arrivé à Abraham en Israël
les enfants de Joseph sont partis en
Égypte et je cite souvent à cette
question du de cette parole du théronome
nous ne pouvons que considérer
l'étranger puisque nous-mêmes nous avons
été étrangers comme nous l'avons été en
Égypte et je m'approprie à titre
personnel ces deux histoires qui me sont
communes donc je ne peux pas souffrir
comme tout être humain en voyant ce qui
se passe en interne mais là où je suis
un peu sceptique c'est qu'on passe une
éthique de conviction du pape puisqu'on
fait le cuminisme je cité Weber qui est
un processant comme tout le monde le
sait cette éthique de consignation à
l'éthique de responsabilité et je crains
et je crains et je pèse mes mots que le
pape
ne tombe pas dans l'éthique de
responsabilité
on ne comprend pas ce qui se passe de la
migration des peuples
subsahariens qui passent par la Tunisie
par la Libye où ils sont profondément
maltraités jusqu'en
Occident où ils sont accueillis à bras
ouverts et c'est pas un hasard si les
rencontres de la Méditerranée ne se
tiennent pas autrement que l'Occident
les 3e vous avez je vous ai écouté avec
beaucoup d'attention madame hier elles
ont commencé à barrir où c'était des
rencontres entre-évêques et ce sont
poursuits à Florence le pape n'est pas
venu parce qu'il avait un problème de
genou où c'était avec les maires de la
Méditerranée et le pape des accueillis
moi j'aimerais bien qu'on ait des
rencontres Méditerranées à smirn vous
savez très bien Madame que smirn
n'existe plus cette ville où les Grecs
les Arméniens et les Juifs vivaient en
paix et ça il y a un certain nombre de
vie que ça soit Tripoli en Libye ou que
ça soit Tripoli au Liban ou
malheureusement le pape ne pourrait pas
parler comme il le fait on va y revenir
Emmanuel Macron donc est arrivé dans les
la tribune du stade Vélodrome on va
peut-être regarder le sondage
l'extrait du sondage odoxa backbone
Consulting qui a été fait pour Le Figaro
ce jeudi je le redis à Sacha Baudry en
régie si on peut sortir justement
l'extrait du sondage concernant ce que
pense les Français de la présence
d'Emmanuel Macron à cette messe et bien
vous le voyez 62% des Français
approuvent la présence du président de
la République dans les travées du stade
Vélodrome est-ce que c'est votre cas
est-ce que vous faites partie des 62 %
est-ce que vous partez faites partie des
36%, vous nous le dites vous répondez et
vous nous dites surtout pourquoi on le
partage avec nos internautes on va
revenir sur ce que justement vous vous
venez de dire parce que il y a quand
même par rapport à ce que vous dire il y
a des précisions et le pape François
s'est exprimé justement sur la situation
en Afrique du Nord très clairement avec
notre confrère Jean-Marie guesnoy de
retour de de Lisbonne dans l'avion de
retour de de
juriste
n'est absolument pas est-elle menacée ou
pas par cette présence d'Emmanuel Macron
c'est un faux débat je me souviens avec
beaucoup d'émotions la présence du
général de Gaulle à la cathédrale de
Reims accueillant un des noirs pour la
petite histoire quand elle était noire
est arrivée à Colombey les deux églises
la domestique du général de Gaulle est
parti en pleurant refusant le recevoir
bon il y a des réconciliations qui nous
coûtent mais se sont fait à Reims donc à
partir de ce moment-là on peut pas
critiquer la présence de telle ou telle
la laïcité n'est absolument pas remise
en cause la laïcité n'est pas remise en
cause et quand d'autres hommes ou femmes
politiques se déplacent dans d'autres
cultes on en fait pas tout un débat il y
a un moment donné c'est aussi l'amitié
entre le politique et le religieux qui
permet ce genre de rencontre et je pense
qu'il faut pas évidemment mettre de
débat là où il n'y en a pas il ne
devrait pas y en avoir
la procession d'entrée au stade
Vélodrome
et effectivement on est à Marseille donc
c'est la Vierge Marie qui est à
l'honneur apparemment la Vierge Marie
oui mais vous savez il faut elle garde
sa juste place ce qui est à l'honneur
regardez c'est l'évangéliaire qui est
porté en procession c'est-à-dire cette
Parole de Dieu qui vient interpeller les
chrétiens et le monde sur ce qu'ils font
justement
dans notre monde et la manière dont il
répondent à l'appel de Dieu c'est c'est
d'abord la croix de procession et
l'évangéliaire qui sont portés devant
toutes ces personnes c'est eux qui nous
éclaire et pour revenir au sujet que
nous avons évoqué vous savez c'est
Saint-Jean-de-la-Croix avait cette très
belle parole au soir de notre vie chaque
personne sera jugée sur l'amour sur
l'amour que l'on aura mis en oeuvre et
donc quand on est face à ce crucifié
c'est de se poser la question de quel
amour on déploie et pas se poser de
36000 autres questions
un commentaire peut-être également c'est
une réputation ça fait réagir je pensais
les évêques le temps des collègues dit
que le pape françois est un pape plutôt
progressiste par certains côtés
notamment sur le discours là on voit
s'adresse à vous persévrier Burga en
matière liturgique ça a l'air quand même
si vous le spécialiste mais ça m'a l'air
assez traditionnel c'est je sais pas
s'il faut le qualifier de traditionnel
c'est classique ce qui peut peut-être
surprendre les spectateurs de cette
Eucharistie c'est que le pape François
ne préside la messe sans la célébrer
c'est d'ailleurs le signe de de du
vêtement qu'il vient de de revêtir
maintenant il a une chape et non pas une
chasuble la chape étant une espèce de
grande cape vous la voyez sur les écrans
et en fait depuis quelques mois deux
trois ans me semble-t-il de mémoire le
pape François à cause de la fatigue et
notamment de la difficulté à être en
position debout ne célèbre plus la messe
il la préside et vous voyez que c'est le
cardinal à l'aveline qui va célébrer la
messe en tant que telle et donc le pape
François est là en signe de présidents
il donnera l'homélie il donnera la
bénédiction et c'est le cardinal à
velvin qui célébrera la messe
c'est-à-dire qui consacrera le pain et
le vin c'est une petite distinction
liturgique mais qui existait déjà qui
existe depuis le rite de Vatican II dont
les évêques et le pape et l'évêque de
Rome dont les évêques se servent peu
mais qui est un rite qui est une
présidence qui existe depuis 60 ans et
qui ne surprend pas les ceux qui sont
habitués de la liturgie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on laisse vivre quelques instants on a
laissé vivre quelques instants une
ferveur qui a un particulière dans ces
dans ces travées du stade du Stade
Vélodrome avec effectivement cette
première qui est cette messe et cette
messe qui fera donc pas célébrée mais
présidé par le pape François et célébré
par le cardinal archevêque de Marseille
monseigneur le cardinal Jean-Marc
haveline
c'est aujourd'hui l'un des rares
cardinaux français mais il devrait avoir
d'autres cardinaux à venir dans les
semaines à venir oui mais il y a le
cardinal de l'évêque de Corse
Monseigneur burtillo qui sera créé
cardinal prochainement vous voyez que le
pape président la messe va introduire le
rite de la messe
maintenant
[Applaudissements]
bonjour Marcel
bonjour la France
au nom de Père et de Fils et du
Saint-Esprit
la paix soit avec vous
[Musique]
oui c'est fermé le péché c'est pourquoi
j'ai souffert
et vous aussi faire des pieds pour moi
le Seigneur de Dieu
que Dieu tu puissant vous fasse mixer
les cours que nous perdons nos spécifier
et nous grandissent à l'Éternel
[Musique]
juste un mot
le pape célèbre en français c'est une
langue qui comprend mais qui ne parle
pas c'est ça
quand vous lui parliez vous lui parlez
en français Isabelle j'ai voulu parier
espagnol faut dire qu'il faut rappeler
que vous avez été ambassade vous avez
été ambassadrice au Mexique et vous
aviez été d'ailleurs à la massasuda
droites ah non non c'était bien après
c'était après votre passage
et vous avez été donc ambassadrice en
Afrique également en Haïti où là on
parle français
oui on parlait de moins en moins si on
parle créole d'abord et avant tout mais
enfin il y a une langue qui finit tout
le les haïtien il y a quelque chose de
paradoxal
finalement on parle de mondialisation et
on dit que le pape François c'est le
pape de la mondialisation et ce
phénomène de la mondialisation il
commence
dans les années 50-60 et après amplifier
avec la chute du mur de Berlin et
paradoxalement ça à ce moment-là que
l'Église a rompu avec la langue
universelle avec le latin même s'il le
latin est conservé mais qui n'est pas
devenu le
laisser les langues les langues
nationales vernaculaires oui mais on a
laissé les langues vernaculaires se
développer notamment à travers la
liturgie depuis le Concile Vatican II et
puis c'est vrai que le latin est une
langue qui était de moins en moins
utilisée il faut rappeler aussi que le
il y avait certes le latin pour la
liturgie pour l'enseignement pour les
textes officiels et plus vous aviez le
français aussi comme langue diplomatique
du Saint Siège et le Français a été une
langue très longtemps utilisée par le
Saint Siège et donc très utilisé par les
différents papes
c'est la dichotomie du du Concile
Vatican II parce que dans sacrocentreum
concilium il est dit que latin reste la
langue de l'Évangile donc les travaux du
concile les pardon le latin reste la
langue de la liturgie et c'est cette
véritable dichotomie qu'on trouve dans
d'une part les textes-concils et leur
application sachant que le concile et la
messe et la réforme de la messe sont
deux choses différentes ceci dit la
réforme de la liturgie de la messe
découle du Concile Vatican II mais le
Concile Vatican II ne sait pas occupé
que de liturgie
sur les migrations vous parliez de la du
caractère universel de la mondialisation
et le premier texte sur les migrants
puisque la première journée de la
migration et c'est de 1914 et le pape
envoyé sa sollicitude aux Italiens qui
avaient émigré aux États-Unis vous voyez
qu'on était dans un dans un effet
inverse à celui d'aujourd'hui c'est à
l'époque où les
migrants quittaient l'Europe
même s'il y avait un phénomène des
phénomènes d'immigration au sein de
l'Europe puisqu'il y avait quand même
une immigration italienne ou polonaise
qui est en France exactement
lui qui vit un règne avec toi dans
l'unité
et de rappeler que en fait il y a une
forme de symbolique très développée dans
l'Ancien Testament et qui reviendra au
sujet qui nous préoccupe largement
pendant tout ce voyage c'est que le
peuple de Dieu est un peuple en exil qui
marche à travers le désert et qui monte
et qui doit marcher vers la montagne de
Dieu et donc l'horizon de début
reprenait cette symbolique la Vierge
Marie accompagne le peuple qui marche
vers la montagne du Seigneur
alors ça c'était pas forcément annoncé
mais la première lecture elle est en
anglais vous allez pouvoir nous en
donner peut-être la substantifique
moelle
il faudrait regarder
[Musique]
Timothée vous allez nous donner un petit
peu des précisions sur le sur le
programme là on vient d'entendre la
première lecture en anglais est-ce que
ce sera le cas pour la deuxième lecture
et de quelle lecture s'agit-il
vous allez me poser une colle parce que
je ne sais pas précisément en quelle
langue va être prononcé la deuxième
lecture la première vient en tout cas de
se terminer dans un dans un grand grand
silence ce qui est le signe que la foule
ici présente suit vraiment cette messe
et ça c'est quelque chose d'assez à
marquant depuis le début de cette
cérémonie les gens participent
réellement aux champs les gens sont
vraiment à l'écoute et regardent
vraiment ce qui se passe au niveau de
l'hôtel là maintenant c'est le psaume
qui va être qui va être entonné et un
élément également Vincent je sais pas si
vous l'avez vu à la réalisation des
images du Vatican tout à l'heure il y a
eu trois typhos trois tifos qui sont qui
sont qui ont émaner des tribunes des
tribunes de supporters habituels de
l'Olympique de Marseille avec un tifo
notamment du pack François l'effigie du
pape François avec la Bonne Mère
derrière la Vierge Marie voilà donc pour
cette ce début ce début de l'Est et nous
allons retrouver ensemble en quelle
langue la seconde lecture la deuxième
lecture va être prononcée maintenant
effectivement voudrais c'est bien
l'oreille parce que comme ça vous
trouverez les références et on pourra
demander au père du regard de nous en
donner en tous les cas les grandes
lignes
les justes une précision
Timothée parce que tout le monde n'est
pas féru et spécialiste de foot et
stadologues comme vous l'êtes donc
est-ce que vous pouvez préciser quand
même aux internautes qui l'ignorent ce
que sont les tifo
[Musique]
oui bien sûr Vincent les Tibo c'est en
fait une grande banderole une très très
grande banderole de plusieurs mètres
carrés qui est déployé dans le stade et
ce qui se fait généralement au début
d'un grand match de football voilà une
grande banderole avec par exemple un
grand drapeau de la France ce genre de
choses et bien là c'est une très très
grande banderole donc pas de François
qui a donc été déployé au moment où il
est entré dans dans ce stade et puis
également un autre tipo avec cette
banderole avec écrit Merci voilà c'est
un signe de voilà de remerciement de la
part des supporters de l'Olympique de
Marseille
merci beaucoup
Timothée effectivement les supporters de
l'Olympique de Marseille qui pouvait
laisser les travées du vélo de Rome ce
week-end puisque le classico lui aura
lieu demain et ce sera à Paris entre
l'OM et le PSG au Parc des Princes et
c'est d'ailleurs ce même Parc des
Princes qui avait accueilli pour la
première fois un pape c'était Jean-Paul
II en 1980 lors de son premier voyage à
l'époque d'ailleurs il y avait pas de
tifo il y avait écrit effectivement si
si je ne m'abuse Jésus-Christ sur les
sur les panneaux où on affiche
habituellement les
les sens de la première lecture qu'on a
entendu en anglais tout à l'heure avec
cette grande parole qui est assez connue
Jésus-Christ c'est le même hier
aujourd'hui et demain et c'est son sang
qui vient purifier l'humanité de ses
péchés et donc c'est un message qui a
été affirmé avec force dans cette lettre
aux Hébreux que nous avons entendu dans
la première lecture
là il y a normalement il y a qu'une
lecture on devrait avoir le l'Évangile
après normalement oui
après pour les messes un peu solennelles
on peut développer mettre une deuxième
lecture mais c'est pas sûr
oui Timothée
la prochaine traduction nous
indique-t-il donc on l'écoutera
l'Évangile va être proclamé en français
je pense
[Musique]
et effectivement peut-être que là on
reste justement dans la thématique dans
la thématique mariale d'ailleurs c'était
pas le psaume c'était le cantique de la
Vierge Marie
c'est le magnifique a qui est proclamé
là
[Musique]
de la deuxième
donc là il y aura pas de deuxième
lecture apparemment
ça un point intéressant que cette
lecture a été était lu en anglais ce qui
souligne quand même un caractère
international à cette messe et une perte
également du français en tant que langue
universel oui mais faut se rappeler
quand même que le pape est venu à
l'occasion des Rencontres de la
Méditerranée et que donc il y a un
certain nombre d'évêques et de jeunes
qui sont venus de tout le bassin
méditerranéen pour toute cette semaine
de rencontre et donc cette messe qui
vient conclure ces rencontres et pas
d'abord une messe j'allais dire
franco-française c'est une messe pour
célébrer ces journées de la Méditerranée
qu'il y a un caractère international
c'est tout à fait normal
avec le petit signe au début bonjour
Marcel bonjour la France qui clôt la
polémique
[Musique]
donc là apparemment c'est pas parce que
c'est un prêtre qui veut dire
rappelle peut-être ce cardiaque dans
l'Église catholique il y a trois degrés
dans le sacrement de l'Ordre les diacres
les prêtres et les évêques et
traditionnellement c'est au diacre de
proclamer la Parole de Dieu et notamment
l'Évangile
on va voir quel évangile a été choisi
pour cette eucar ici
[Musique]
on encense l'Évangile dans la liturgie
catholique parce que c'est quand même la
Parole de Dieu la plus importante pour
les chrétiens et donc elle est honorée
de cette manière
en route et se rendit avec empressement
vers la région montagneuse dans une
ville de Judée
elle entra dans la maison de Zacharie et
salua Elisabeth
or quand Elisabeth entendit sa
salutation de Marie
l'enfant tressaillit en elle
alors
Elisabeth fut remplie d'Esprit Saint et
s'écria d'une voix forte
tu es bénie entre toutes les femmes
et le fruit de tes entrailles est béni
d'où met-il donné que la mère de mon
Seigneur vienne jusqu'à moi
car lorsque tes paroles de salutations
sont parvenus à mes oreilles
l'enfant a tressailli d'allégresse en
moi
heureuse celle qui a cru à
l'accomplissement des paroles qui lui
furent dites de la part du Seigneur
acclamons la Parole de Dieu
[Musique]
de messe où l'on honore la Vierge Marie
qui est cette Visitation c'est le moment
où Marie après avoir reçu l'annonce de
la grossesse divine va rencontrer sa
cousine Elisabeth qui est enceinte de
Jean-Baptiste
[Musique]
à Jérusalem
parti pour aller la France pendant son
trajet
sur le fond de cette scène
que Luc nous raconte la visite
de Marie à Elizabeth marie aussi se lève
et va vers la région de Jérusalem et
quand elle arrive dans la maison
d'Elizabeth
David devant l'arche
de la viande
qui va nous présenter le Seigneur
incarné dans le monde et la Geneviève
et en portant Jésus les signes de la
visite de Jésus qui va au-delà de toute
stérilité
que Dieu est ton voyage vers nous
pour nous chercher avec son amour une
fois exulter de joie c'est Dieu qui se
met en voyage
il y a donc la visite de Dieu à
l'humanité une plus jeune plus ancienne
une vierge une stérile
enceinte de façon impossible toutes les
deux
c'est l'œuvre de Dieu dans notre vie
qui rend possible l'impossible qui
génère la vie même dans la stérilité
de cœur
est-ce que nous croyons que Dieu est en
œuvre dans notre vie on ne croit
vraiment est-ce qu'on croit que le
Seigneur se fasse son cacher
et de façon aussi imprévisible
dans l'histoire
accomplissent des merveilles
soit l'oeuvre aussi dans nos sociétés
dans nos sociétés séculaire et aussi
marqué par une certaine indifférence
religieuse
on peut discerner cette confiance qu'on
peut avoir dans le Seigneur comment
salutations de Marie l'enfant a
tressailli en son sein
le Seigneur
on sent quelque chose qui bouge qui qui
danse une danse de joie
je voudrais
souligner
l'exaltation de la foi l'expérience de
la foi
créer une joie face à la vie
à l'intérieur
froid immobile
ce commode d'une vie
basique qui se ferme qui se renferme
dans l'indifférence et qui devient
imperméable
qui devient dur
tu deviens insensible à tout et à tout
le monde même
elle a dit humaine
ainsi comme dans de nombreux enfants non
nés et de nombreuses personnes âgées
abandonnées
vide de façon mécanique son patient sans
élan
sans envie
et on peut en tomber malade dans cet
européenne de tout cela peut tomber
malade de sinisme ou des enchantement
d'incertitude et aussi de tristesse
[Musique]
une vie sans essayer
Seigneur comme l'enfant dans le dans le
ventre d'Elizabeth on trouve l'oeuvre
dans tout ce qui s'est passé
malgré la fatigue les problèmes les
souffrances on peut voir tous les jours
la visite de Dieu
et ce sont donc accompagnés et aidés
de la société
qui croit
peut tressaillir
à une passion
à un rêve un rêve à cultiver
avec un intérêt qu'il a envie de
s'impliquer en première personne
chacun de nous peut donc se demander
est-ce que je ressens tout ça
j'ai tout ça
que le Seigneur est tout le temps
présent il nous appelle dans notre vie à
témoigner de l'Évangile
pouvoir témoigner qu'un nouveau monde
est impossible
l'expérience de la foi n'est pas
simplement très sére face à la vie mais
cela peut s'y créer générer une joie
face à l'autre au prochain dans le
mystère de la de la Visitation
pour voir que la visite de Dieu
n'a pas lieu à travers des événements
exceptionnels célestes mais dans la
simplicité d'une rencontre
Dieu a et là sur l'entrée d'une maison
dans ces deux femmes qui se rencontrent
c'est de femmes enceintes plein de super
d'espoir dans cette rencontre et la
sollicitude de Marie
les merveillement des abeilles
la joie du partage
Dieu est relation et Dieu nous rend
visite souvent à travers des rencontres
humaines
quand on a cette joie pour la vie et
pour la joie de la vie que des personnes
qui passent à côté de nous et quand
notre cœur
mais pas sensible immobile face face va
se blessures des plus fragiles
européens la France
nous vivons ensemble des cultures et des
religions différentes
sont un défi un défi contre
l'exaspération de l'individualisme
contre l'égoïsme contre les fermetures
qui ne peuvent que créer de la solitude
et de l'indifférence
apprenons de la part de Jésus
à côté de nous apprenons de Jésus
avoir de la compassion
on tressaillir de miséricorde face à la
chair blessée de ce qu'on rencontre
nous devons
rendre nos cœurs plus tendres les rendre
sensible sensible aux peines et aux
misères de nos prochains et prier Dieu
pour qu'il puisse nous donner
le vrai esprit de miséricorde
qui est son propre esprit en réalité
sont mon Seigneur
une histoire riche de sainteté de
culture
d'artistes
aujourd'hui aussi notre ville la vie de
l'Église la vie de la France la ville de
l'Europe
il y a pas besoin de tout cela de la
grâce d'entrément
notre escalement de foi de charité et
d'espoir
ils ont besoin de retrouver la passion
la passion est l'enthousiasme
[Musique]
et l'enthousiasme
redécouvrir
le goût de l'effort pour la fraternité
l'amour pour les familles et pour les
plus faibles
redevenir une grâce qui transforme
errante belle la vie
qui voyage
il nous fait nous déplacer nous fêter
c'est ce qui arrive à Elisabeth
des chrétiens qui rencontrent Dieu avec
la prière
elle est propre avec l'amour les
chrétiens qui peuvent vibrer et
accueillir le Feu de l'Esprit
de se laisser brûler
des filles de Méditerranée
l'utopie de fraternité et de paix
qui attendent d'être réalisé
Notre Dame de la Garde
qu'elle puisse veiller sur votre vie
Paul Claudel
je vois une église ouverte
pour te regarder
pleurer de joie et savoir ceci que je
suis ton fils et que tu es là
avec toi Marie dans le lieu où tu es
là pour toujours
parce que tu as la Vierge Marie
simplement parce que tu existes
je te remercie merci
[Applaudissements]
c'est une courte médique vient de
prononcer le pape François
une Mélie qui a été largement
consacrée qui a fait référence à pas mal
de figures qui parlent aux Français qui
parlent aux Marseillais bien sûr avec
une conclusion sur Notre-Dame de la
Garde que Notre-Dame de la Garde garde
la France et l'Europe
vers Cédric burgien je tourne vers vous
c'est une homélie qui a nettement plus
nettement moins politique beaucoup plus
spirituelle que ce qu'on a entendu
jusqu'à présent je sais pas si elle est
moins politique parce que quand on la
décryptera je pense qu'on verra tous les
messages qui sont envoyés par contre
spécifiquement politique en tous les cas
que ce qu'on a moins explicitement
politique mais en tout cas elle invite à
plusieurs choses et le pape François a
eu des mots très forts si vous me
permettrez j'en retiendrai au moins
trois d'abord il a il a parlé de la
sainte
utopie de la fraternité il se rend bien
compte que le message de la fraternité
universelle qu'il développe est une
forme d'utopie d'idéalisme mais quelque
part quand on reprend le message de
l'Évangile les paroles du Christ sont
très fortes et très radicales et quelque
part très utopique quand Jésus dit si on
te frappe sur la joue droite tant la
joue gauche il a une forme du Topin dans
cette parole et donc le pape revient à
une forme de radicalité évangélique à
travers cette belle expression de la
sainte utopie de la fraternité ensuite
moi qui suis évidemment très très engagé
dans l'Église de France on va pas me le
nier mais j'ai retenu que le pape
François a demandé que la France qui
avait connu tant de philosophes de
penseurs etc retrouve le tressaillement
la passion et l'enthousiasme et donc il
y a un message qui vient quelque part
nous bousculer là aussi est-ce que nous
ne sommes pas encore trop endormis
dans dans et quand il a dit retrouver la
passion et l'enthousiasme le goût de
l'effort dans la fraternité par rapport
aux familles au plus fragile au plus
faible et donc il y a véritablement un
message d'encouragement et de réveil des
consciences et puis vous me permettrez
c'est là que je soulignerai que la
parole du pape François avec quelques
peu été quelque peu politique il a
évoqué la figure de Saint-Vincent de
Paul et saint Vincent de Paul on oublie
trop souvent que c'est pas simplement le
saint qui fait la charité dans les rues
de Paris Saint Vincent-de-Paul a utilisé
le fait qu'il avait l'oreille du roi
pour améliorer la condition des
galériens à Marseille et donc il y a un
message très politique en évoquant la
figure de Saint-Vincent de Paul dans le
Melly du pape ça ne sonne Paul qui avait
été enlevé
par les Barbaresques et
musulmane et amené à Tunis où il a été
détenu en captivité en tous les cas à
l'époque de Saint-Vincent de Paul par
rapport aux galériens on disait le
pouvoir politique disait qu'il en
faisait déjà suffisamment et donc voyez
quelque part il y a toujours cette
tension entre le religieux et le
politique qui viennent s'interpeller
l'un l'autre ils avaient le temps
qu'est-ce qui vous a frappé dans ces
tout à fait en ligne est-ce que je viens
de dire le père parce que je trouve et
voilà le c'est exactement ce que j'avais
ce que j'ai retenu et puis le triptyque
foi charité espoir et puis cet appel au
fond c'est aussi une autre façon de
décliner n'ayez pas peur de dire voilà
veillez pas peur vous avez des ressorts
il y a des ressorts voilà utiliser les
voilà
l'endurcissement du cœur le pharisien la
figure du pharisien c'est Seigneur celui
qui qui pratique
mais qui oublie l'amour et on ça nous
renvoie la parabole du bon Samaritain le
prêtre qui passe le lévite qui passe et
le Samaritain c'était à l'étranger par
rapport à Israël vous savez que les
Samaritains et les et nos frères scénés
dans la foi n'avait de très mauvaises
relations donc c'est ça que c'est la
figure de l'endurcissement qui me fait
penser aux Pharisiens encore une fois
celui qui croit qu'il est sauvé alors
qu'il manque profondément d'amour il y a
Samaritain qui est dans les toutes
premières pages de l'encyclique
fratellioté il y a également quelque
chose d'assez frappant dans ce que l'on
vient de voir pendant qu'on discutait
c'était le grand silence qui a eu lieu
après qui est succédé à l'Évangile
ça rappelle là aussi un tournant dans la
façon dont les messes
[Musique]
sur saisie de ce silence je peux vous
dire que ça vous prend aux tripes
c'est sans doute une libanaise ou une
syrienne qui est en train de s'exprimer
et
ce que ce que vous venez de dire c'est
en fait la vraie parole du pape aux
migrants serait celle-ci
vous venez pour des questions
économiques mais tournez-vous aussi vers
cette civilisation européenne et vous
européens ce n'est pas parce que vous
les accueillez avec de la matérialité
que votre effort est suffisant et c'est
pour moi c'est seul la seule
spiritualité qui pourra
entraîner cette coexistence entre les
deux moi je suis frappé quand je vois
des jeunes musulmans en France
parce que disait le pape dans son
homélie cette joie on a perdu la joie
dans cette vieille Europe et ce qu'a dit
le Pape sur le chien dans la poussette
c'est exactement ça mais où sont les
enfants en Europe or l'enfant est une
source de générosité de croyances en la
future d'espérance et évidemment de
charité donc les enfants et ce qu'a dit
le Pape François sur l'accueil de la vie
à avec la figure du migrant est
éminemment aussi politique
bon je m'arrêterai là
la ceinture
est-ce que là encore vous êtes on est
dans ce que penser qu'on est dans ce que
vous disiez entre l'éthique de
conviction et l'éthique de
responsabilité ça dépasse c'est-à-dire
que le message du pape c'est comme l'a
dit le prête c'est l'expression de la
radicalité l'Évangile c'est pour ça que
je n'aime pas l'inférence du pape dans
nos affaires ce n'est pas à lui de
déterminer qui on doit accueillir et
comment on doit le cueillir par contre
il doit nous chaque fois nous faire
penser
au salut qui doit nous animer parce que
en fait le pape nous rappelle
l'espérance qu'on a dans l'au-delà et
c'est cette joie qui peut nous éliminer
sur terre c'est l'espérance de l'au-delà
donc il n'y a pas seulement cette
matérialité qui est propre à l'Europe
aujourd'hui la matérialité qui pousse
l'Allemagne a demandé un million de
migrants en 2015 et de les intégrer
uniquement pour des raisons économiques
mais aussi cette
soif de spiritualité et quand le pape
parle de la similisation stérile
personnellement j'y vois une insérance
quand j'écoute les quand j'écoute le
serment l'expression d'évangile j'y vois
une question d'espérance y compris pour
moi-même on va retrouver Timothée délène
qui est au stade Vélodrome qui suit
cette visite pour Le Figaro et pour
Figaro live
Timothée il y a quelque chose de très
frappant dans ce que l'on a vu d'abord
c'était
l'émotion
sur les sur les visages pendant la le
discours du Pape François et le grand
silence qui a suivi c'est cet Obélix
[Musique]
oui tout à fait Vincent c'est vrai que
c'est quelque chose d'ici de très très
saisissant salé vous le disiez tout à
l'heure en plateau lorsque l'on voit les
images sur un écran mais je peux vous
garantir que c'est également le cas
encore plus certainement lorsqu'on est
présent sur place c'est vrai que autant
pendant l'homélie les fidèles étaient
extrêmement attentif à ce que disait le
pape François puisque nous avons la
traduction ici qui s'affiche sur les sur
les écrans géants autant ils ont été
extrêmement silencieux encore plus au
moment où le pape François a terminé son
à terminer son son homélie un temps
assez long de recueillement il y a eu
quelques applaudissements et puis
ensuite ce temps de recueillement de
prière et avec un grand grand silence
dans ce dans ce stade Vélodrome qui est
assez peu habitué donc c'est vrai que
c'est quelque chose d'assez d'assez
saisissant ici c'est ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure les fidèles on
sent qu'ils sont là vraiment pour pour
prier et c'est quelque chose que l'on
ressent véritablement ici on les voit
voilà on est vraiment entouré de gens
qui sont venus ici pour payer autour du
bac français est-ce quelque chose de
très flagrant on voit ces visages qui
sont vraiment recueillis et on les fait
et on espère en retrouver certains après
la messe on compte sur vous il y a une
chose qui est également frappante en
tous les cas dans les images qui nous
sont renvoyés c'est la jeunesse de
l'assistance
la jeunesse oui Vincent mais je moi je
voulais vous dire tout à l'heure une
assistance très très familiale c'est
vrai qu'on a on a croisé tout à l'heure
en particulier lorsque nous étions en
train de nous rendre dans les travées du
stade beaucoup de familles des gens qui
sont venus voilà tous ensemble avec donc
les parents également des jeunes oui
surtout pour les pour ce qui est des
mouvements beaucoup de mouvements de
scoutisme qui sont là on les repère
évidemment avec leur uniformes avec
leurs foulards donc c'est vrai qu'il y a
beaucoup de jeunes mais il y a également
également des des têtes un petit peu
plus un peu plus grises si je peux s'il
peut l'exprimer ainsi
le blanc c'est pas un tard d'en avoir
merci beaucoup Timothée vous disiez
Philippe Fontana oui je laisse
occidental
de parler aux migrants qui se sont
établis à marseille est une ville comme
il en a vu hier quand même oui mais hier
ils avaient été justement un jeune
migrant qui c’était un texte de saint
Paul c'était un migrant c'était un
migrant qui est arrivé en France à l'âge
de 16 ans bien sûr ils ont été choisis
et sélectionnés je dois dire qu'il est
dommage que le message
exprimé par le pape là le message
évangélique et du mal à porter aux
migrants qui se sont installés depuis
une dizaine d'années depuis le
l'avènement du du pontificat du
Saint-Père et cette difficulté à leur
parler de la parole du Christ à quoi
vous voyez ça qu'il a une difficulté à
porter ça parce qu'il y a sans doute
peut-être des des migrants des
demandeurs d'asile ou des réfugiés qui
sont ici au vélo oui on les voit pas
beaucoup
c'est un problème de réalisation
peut-être je ne crois pas j'aimerais
qu'on voit beaucoup plus de personnes
étrangères la robe qui adhèrent un
message de Christ donc au message du
pape père burgien on dit aussi que il y
en a certains qui le font et en
particulier de gens qui sont
convertissent de l'islam qui se
convertissent de l'Islam au
christianisme mais qui pour l'instant
garde plutôt le silence pour ne pas
dire de persécution c'est pour ça que
pardonnez-moi mais je pense que c'est un
faux débat déjà parce que c'est une
eucharistie et non pas et vous l'avez
souligné tout à l'heure non pas une
rencontre politique et que dans cette
Eucharistie il y a évidemment
une foule très disparate qu'on ne voit
pas de manière précise et justement
parce que certains migrants qui se
convertissent aux catholicisme en terre
occidental ont parfois beaucoup de
difficultés à témoigner de cette
conversion parce que cela va leur poser
un certain nombre de problèmes
d'ailleurs il y a un certain nombre de
de questions juridiques qui se posent
sur l'asile pour des demandes
religieuses et donc c'est une réalité
aujourd'hui en France qui se pose et qui
montre bien qu'il y a une attention de
l'église à cette réalité
alors je vous rassure dans le
ironiquement c'est plus la l'Asie
climatique dont la question se pose et
d'ailleurs qui a été relevée hier par le
pape et qui pose beaucoup de
préoccupations autorités françaises je
dis pas que c'était la majorité mais je
veux dire cette réalité là elle existe
mais elle est encore cachée et
d'ailleurs c'est une c'est une vraie
préoccupation de l'Église de France que
de faire attention à ces personnes qui
se convertissent aux catholicisme et
qu'on ne les met pas en danger y compris
sur le territoire français mais il est
dommage que l'Église n'exprime pas sa
plus grande sollicitude envers ses
frères qui se convertissent et n'appuie
pas sur la demande de la liberté
religieuse que ça soit en France ou dans
le pourtour de la Méditerranée et
puisque vous vous expliquez que c'était
une célébration eucharistique chez les
chez les Romains
et bien les
ceux qui voulaient se convertir quitter
à la deuxième partie de la messe et
pouvait entendre jusque jusqu'à la
partie du sermon donc peut-être que dans
une utopie fraternelle le tiers du stade
se serait vidé avant la partie
sacrificielle de la messe on restera
dans la partie sacrificielle de la messe
c'est celle dans laquelle on est en
train de rentrer apparemment
entre guillemets reprend la main si vous
me pardonnez l'expression j'en trouve
pas d'autre c'est lui qui va célébrer et
donc consacrer avec les prêtres et les
évêques présents le pain et le vin qui
pour les catholiques rendent présents le
Corps et le Sang du Seigneur c'est la
partie la plus importante oui enfin
après le Concile Vatican II rappelait
qu'il y avait une seule table la table
de la parole et de l'Eucharistie il est
vrai que il y a 60 ans en arrière on
avait l'habitude d'arriver en retard à
la messe et qu'on se disait tant qu'on
était arrivé jusqu'à l'offertoire on
n'était pas en retard aujourd'hui on
insiste sur le fait que la Parole de
Dieu est aussi j'allais dire autant
importante c'est une seule table qui
fait l'unité de la célébration de la
Messe et c'est pour ça que les fidèles
sont tellement en retard aujourd'hui que
les églises sont vides
en tout cas c'est pas le cas du Stade
Vélodrome qui lui est plein et à
l'intérieur des travées et autour du
stade avec donc cette messe qui est
présidée par le pape François et célébré
par le cardinal Jean-Marc Aveline que
l'on voit en ce moment
glorifier car elle a conçu ton fils
unique lorsque le Saint-Esprit la
couvrit de son ombre et gardant pour
toujours la gloire de sa virginité elle
a donné au monde la lumière éternelle
Jésus le Christ notre Seigneur
par lui les anges célèbres ta grandeur
et les esprits bienheureux adorent ta
gloire par lui s'incline devant toi les
puissances d'en haut et très sale d'une
même allégresse les innombrables
créatures des cieux à leur hymne de
louange laisse-nous joindre nos voix
pour chanter et proclamer
[Musique]
que tu ne prophétiser ce qu'on est en
train de vivre justement
père Burgat on connaît à leur jonction
des deux parties de la messe
là après ce qu'on a après ce qu'on
appelle la préface c'est une grande
prière de louange à Dieu pour le mystère
que l'on célèbre aujourd'hui l'Institut
d'une prière de de louange pour ce
qu'est la Vierge Marie il y a donc ce
champ du Santos qui résonne saint saint
le Seigneur qui est une des grandes
des grandes exhortation à la louange de
la Parole de Dieu que l'on retrouve à
toutes les eucharistes
le cardinal Aveline vous l'aviez vu à
Rome
il était vous l'avez rencontré assez
souvent quel souvenir et quel souvenir
et vous a laissé
le souvenir de ce qui donne là je veux
dire d'un homme absolument lumineux
extraordinairement simple mais en même
temps d'un puissant théologien j'ai
écouté
[Musique]
ce qu'il a fait au moment de la il a
donné une conférence au moment de la
canonisation de Charles de Foucauld qui
était
brillantissime je peux dire
on reviendra sur la
figure de Charles de Foucault qui a été
canonisée qui s'est converti tout près
d'ici d'ailleurs et qui a été
évoqué et invoqué hier par le pape
François alterner
le Christ notre Seigneur
au moment d'être livré et d'entrer
librement dans sa passion
il prit le pain il rendit grâce
ils
le donna ses disciples en disant
prenez
et manger en
tout ceci est mon corps livré pour vous
de même après le repas il prit la coupe
de nouveau il vendit grâce et la donna
ses disciples en disant
prenez
et buvez en tous par ceci est la courbe
de mon sang le sang de l'Alliance
nouvelle éternelle qui sera versée pour
vous et pour la multitude
en rémission des péchés
vous ferez cela en mémoire de moi
[Musique]
acclamons le mystère de la foi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en faisant ainsi mémoire de la mort et
de la résurrection de ton Fils nous
t'offrons Seigneur le pain de la vie et
la coupe du salut et nous te rendons
grâce à tu nous as estimé digne de nous
tenir devant toi pour te servir
humblement nous te demandons qu'en
n'ayant pas au corps et au sang du
Christ nous soyons rassemblés par
l'Esprit Saint en un seul corps
souviens-toi seigneur de ton Église
répandue à travers le monde fait leur
grandir dans ta charité en union avec
notre Pape François mon frère jambes
avec de cette église de Marseille
moi-même ton humble serviteur et tous
les CV les prêtres et les diacres
souviens-toi aussi de nos frères et
sœurs qui se sont endormis dans
l'espérance de la résurrection
et souviens-toi dans ta miséricorde de
tous les défunts
accueille les dans la lumière de ton
visage
sur nous tous enfin nous implorons ta
bonté permet qu'avec la Vierge Marie la
bienheureuse Mère de Dieu avec saint
Joseph son époux les apôtres et tous les
saints qui ont fait ta joie au long des
âges nous ayons part à la vie éternelle
et que nous chantions talons
et ta gloire
par ton fils Jésus le Christ
[Musique]
par lui avec lui hier en lui
à toi Dieu le Père tout-puissant dans
l'unité du Saint-Esprit
tout honneur et tout gloire pour les
siècles des siècles
[Musique]
alors faire Cédric burgien je profite de
votre présence pour que vous nous
expliquiez parce que là on voyait que ce
n'était plus le cardinal Aveline qui
avait la parole
c'est ce qu'on appelle des
conseillérants dans la dans
l'Eucharistie dans la messe et vous
pouvez avoir des conseils et les grands
principaux qui vont à l'un à leur tour
prendre une part de la prière
eucharistique nous avons notre père en
latin
[Musique]
surtout le noir
S
[Musique]
délivre-nous de tout mal Seigneur et
donne la paix à notre temps
soutenu par ta miséricorde nous serons
libérés de tout péché à l'abri de toute
épreuve nous qui attendons que ce
réalise cette bienheureuse espérance
l'avènement de Jésus-Christ notre
Sauveur
vibration et la messe continue ici à
Marseille là aussi c'est un moment
également important de la messe
puisque c'est là où il y a un geste de
fraternité et d'abord un geste de paix
avant de distribuer la sainte communion
et ce geste de paix avant la communion
sans racine dans une parole du Christ
dans l'Évangile qui avait dit avant
d'aller
traiter de ton offrande sur l'hôtel si
tu as quelque chose contre ton frère va
d'abord te réconcilier avec ton frère et
donc ce geste de fraternité sans racine
là on ne peut pas communier au corps du
Christ si on se sent
en désaccord ou si on a quelque chose
qu'on train de se faire
je note au passage que les deux qu'on
célébrants principaux que vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure ne sont pas des
évêques français et donc c'est aussi une
un signe pour le cardinal Aveline et
pour le pape pour montrer que c'était
une réunion d'évêque de la Méditerranée
et non pas d'abord eu une messe pour
l'Église de France
[Musique]
pour l'Église de France les dossiers
importants aujourd'hui
sont vous disiez l'Église de France et
pas tellement en forme il y a eu la
crise bien évidemment la crise pédophile
il y a d'autres dossiers qui sont
on voit bien aujourd'hui que il y a une
crise vocationnelle une crise
institutionnelle de l'Église de France
mais en note quand même que l'Église de
France garde aussi un vrai dynamisme la
délégation aux Journées Mondiales de la
Jeunesse cet été compté plus de 40 000
jeunes c'était l'une des plus grosses
délégations à travers l'Europe
aujourd'hui on voit bien que le fait
d'avoir rempli le vélo de Rome le stade
du vélo de Rome aujourd'hui et donc à la
fois l'Église de France a il y a des
faiblesses au niveau institutionnel et à
la fois un vrai dynamisme quand même par
rapport à la fois et au vécu des
croyants aujourd'hui on a évoqué
également sur sur ce plateau parce que
ça a été un véritable phénomène qu'on a
observé au printemps dernier la vigueur
encore du mouvement traditionneliste le
Pape a pris des mesures sur cette
question là
ça crée des roues ou également au sein
de ça crée des vrais incompréhensions
n'ayons pas peur de le dire et donc
effectivement cette question est encore
un dossier qui est à qui est à traiter à
la fois par le sans siège et à la fois
par l'Église de France puisque il y a
quand même effectivement chez nous un
vrai courant
voici celui qui enlève les péchés du
monde heureux les invités au repas des
noces de l'Agneau
[Applaudissements]
000 fidèles qui sont en train de
communier dans le stade Vélodrome ça
risque de te prendre un petit peu de
temps j'assure
je vois bien pour les JMJ où il y a
beaucoup plus de monde que cela en
général ça ne s'est très bien organisé
le Saint-Siège est habitué de ce grand
rassemblement ce genre de grand
rassemblement comme sur la place
Saint-Pierre d'ailleurs
je pourrais juste rajouter un mot sur
l'église etc il y a aussi moi ce que
j'appelle l'église l'église à bas bruit
c'est-à-dire tout cet écosystème
catholique ou d'inspiration catholique
qui œuvre modestement ou moins
modestement je veux dire ce
qu'on voit tous les jours quand on se
promène par exemple dans Paris elle
apporte les petits déjeuners les soupes
populaires les cours
[Musique]
on parlait hier de l'oeuvre d'Orient
l'oeuvre d'Orient à une
un système je dirais un dispositif
extraordinairement déployé je veux dire
sur justement
l'éduc la langue française pour intégrer
c'est assez remarquable là et vous avez
quand je dis écosystème c'est parce que
ce n'est pas réservé aux catholiques
c'est vraiment moi je pense l'église
ouverte
et ça on en paraissait peu finalement
mais par contre on le voit on les croise
quand vous êtes passant vous croisez ça
passez vous allez à la soupe populaire à
Saint-Eustache à se à sa mairie ou
ailleurs tout ça ça existe
et c'est pour ça que tout à l'heure je
je
sous forme d'interpellation je disais
qu'est-ce qu'on met sous la réalité
d'église de France parce que souvent on
se focalise sur les questions
institutionnelles en oubliant qu'il y a
tous ces chrétiens qui pratiquent le
dimanche
j'allais dire qui remplissent les
églises même si elles sont plus ou moins
remplies d'ailleurs mais je veux dire
tous ces pratiquants qui viennent
célébrer leur follement et qui vivent
leur foi au quotidien dans le milieu
associatif dans l'entreprise dans la
famille etc et qui font en fait qui qui
vivent une forme de sainteté cachée mais
bien réel
il y a aussi actuellement
en tout cas un dossier important dans
l'Église c'est la pardon j'y reviens sur
les questions institutionnelles c'est la
réforme en tous les cas de la de la
gouvernance de l'église on en est où
c'est un dossier qui se poursuit mais
vous savez de de siècles en siècle cette
question de la gouvernance ecclésiale
c'est toujours posé quelque part et donc
il y a le au mois d'octobre il y aura un
événement extrêmement important qui est
le synode sur la synodalité qui doit se
saisir de justement de ce sujet déjà et
vous savez qu'il y aura plus de de
mémoire 380 participants à Rome des
évêques des prêtres et des laïques qui
vont réfléchir à justement à la question
de la gouvernance ecclésiale mais ceci
note sur la sinodalité il va être en
deux étapes il y a la première étape au
mois d'octobre il y a une étape dans
deux ans il y aura la deuxième étape
dans deux ans entre temps il y aura
aussi toute une réflexion qui va se
développer dans les diocèses et dans les
conférences épiscopales et donc le pape
François a mis ce dossier sur la table
et donc il va falloir voir comment à
partir du Synode ce sujet est saisi dans
l'église la question pour pour ceux qui
nous rejoignent et pour ceux qui nous
suivent et qui sont pas forcément
tellement au fait de ce genre de
subtilité c'est de savoir qui en fait a
vraiment le pouvoir au sein de l'Église
il faut se poser la question aussi de
quelle structure eccléesiales on parle
si on parle du diocèse si on parle de
l'église à l'échelle d'un pays ou si on
parle de l'église au niveau universel
jusqu'à présent il y avait le l'église
enfin Rome et puis les diocèses il y a
une structure qui a pris les conférences
il y a une structure qui a pris depuis
des années effectivement prépondérante
Philippe Fontain Aldi elles sont
récentes ce sont ses conférences
épiscopales comme la Conférence des
évêques de France mais c'est des
structures au regard de l'histoire bi
millénaire de l'église qui sont assez
récentes mais en fait elles sont
récentes oui et non c'est à dire que la
Conférence des évêques et non pas la
conférence et puisqu'elle c'est une
erreur théologique de parler de
conférence épiscopale parce que la
conférence merci de ma cause c'est une
conférence qui réunit les évêques en
tant qu'ils sont chefs de leur diocèse
et non pas eu comme une sorte de
collégialité épiscopale en soi sur un
territoire d'un pays mais en fait
un ciel elle proviennent surtout du
Concile Vatican II c'est conférences des
évêques avant il y avait une autre
réalité qui a cédé un peu la place c'est
la province ecclésiastique c'est à dire
qu'un évêque était rarement seul chez
lui il fonctionnait en province avec ce
que l'on appelle un archevêque que vous
avez mentionné la le la figure du
cardinal Aveline tout à l'heure il est
archevêque de la province de Marseille
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait il est un peu le
celui qui parmi les évêques de la
province de Marseille veille sur ses
frères évêques et puis quand il y a des
problèmes et serait plutôt chargé
d'intervenir dans cette province qui
était le cas dans cette province et donc
avant le concile Vatican II les choses
se régler surtout au sein d'une province
ecclésiastique maintenant la Conférence
des évêques a pris un peu le dessus mais
il faut rappeler deux choses d'une part
c'est qu'une conférence des évêques n'a
pas de pouvoir de gouvernement sur
l'ensemble du pays les décisions qui
sont les quelques décisions qui sont
pris au sein d'une conférence doivent
être reçus et légiférés par chaque
évêque dans son diocèse et donc ce qui
montre bien que la Conférence des
évêques en soi n'a pas de pouvoir de
gouvernement ni d'un pouvoir de
doctrinal en fait elle donne des
indications pour l'Église et puis
ensuite la deuxième chose c'est que elle
a pris un peu le dessus face à ses
provinces ecclésiastiques mais aussi
grâce aux j'allais dire au développement
des moyens de réunion évidemment quand
il y a deux ou trois siècles les
déplacements étaient beaucoup moins
possibles et donc ont fonctionnait bien
plus en province ecclésiastique qu'à
l'échelle d'un pays il n'empêche que les
conférences épiscopales ont fait
beaucoup de mal à les conférences
des évêques complètement
affûté on fait beaucoup de mal puisque
je me souviens que dans les années 70
les évêques tergiverser sur la
dissuasion nucléaire française
c'était c'était un point qui qui
n'arrivait pas à mettre avec dans le
grand mouvement de mondialisation c'est
les années 70 c'est la mondialisation
pour la paix aujourd'hui c'est la
mondialisation par les migrants c'est un
peu la même chose c'est il y a beaucoup
d'idéologie il n'y a pas de résultats et
ensuite la Conférence des évêques a
quand même permis la le l'abandon du
catéchisme en France par la création de
pierre vivante qui était un manuel je
sais pas si ça vous dit quelque chose
qui a fait beaucoup de mal à
l'enseignement du catéchisme et qui a dû
être supprimé justement comme Rome sans
les mêlés
aujourd'hui c'est les choses ont quand
même un peu évolué par rapport à tout ça
père Cédric gourdin oui oui mais vous
savez déjà dans l'église on a une
tradition c'est que on cherche le
consensus les plus grandes décisions
sont prises à plus de deux tiers des
voix et donc quand vous devez mettre
plus de 100 évêques d'accord autour de
la table il faut pas simplement 50% des
voix il faut deux des voix et donc ça
veut dire qu'on recherche le consensus
le plus grand sur les décisions qu'on a
à prendre y compris pour l'élection du
pape d'ailleurs inconclave c'est aux
deux tiers des voix ce qui ferait rougir
de jalousie la plupart de nos dirigeants
politiques qui sont élus avec je ne sais
pas combien de pour cent mais souvent
moins de 50 % avec les faibles taux de
participation et donc vous voyez que ça
prend dirigeant dans les travaux
ce consensus qui est extrêmement fort et
important et bien ça veut dire que
parfois il y a des décisions qui peuvent
sembler trainer mais c'est parce que
dans les dirigeants de l'Église on va
toujours chercher cette unité la plus
forte et la plus grande
est-ce qu'il y a une
si je voudrais ajouter un autre regard
qui est le regard si je puis dire
international la politique
internationale et moi je suis frappée
par l'euro que joue les conférences
épiscopains récents comme pour porter
une voix en particulier en Afrique et
c'est cette voix sur la démocratie sur
la corruption pour justement pointer je
veux dire les mots de ces pays et pas en
particulier les mots des gouvernants
elle est portée par les conférences
épiscopales donc il faut il faut bien
voir je veux dire quand on dit
finalement toutes ces critiques
s'adressent à nous etc mais qui est
aussi tout ce travail je veux dire
décentralisé qui se fait aussi par la
voix des représentants du pape
un autre exemple récent c'est la
création des parce qu'il y a les
conférences des évêques des pays et puis
vous avez des associations de
conférences d'évêque et par exemple vous
avez la conf des conférences des évêques
d'Europe et en fait qui a été créé bien
avant les institutions européennes parce
que les évêques voulaient montrer un
signe de fraternité d'unité à la suite
de la deuxième guerre mondiale la comète
a été également critiquée par certains
comme étant c'est un débat d'ailleurs à
l'intérieur de l'église catholique en
tout cas de chez fidèles comme étant
quand même une instance très tout à fait
son droit mais très européiste très
orienté vers
une forme de supra-nationalité
ce qui ce qui a fait débat est parfois
fait polémique attention parce que là on
évoque deux choses différentes vous avez
évoqué la comédie qui est la Commission
des épiscopa auprès de l'Union
européenne ce qui n'est pas la même
chose que ce que j'évoquais qui est la
le Conseil des conférences des évêques
d'Europe c'est plutôt c'est plutôt cette
question
de de remontrer un visage d'unité de
fraternité possible après la deuxième
guerre mondiale la connaissez a
effectivement pris des des options
politiques enfin si vous ouvrez le
Compendium pour la doctrine sociale de
l'Église vous verrez que la plupart des
Papes est pas simplement François et
c'est repris par le magistère officiel
de l'Église appel à une gouvernance
internationale mondiale parce que pour
la papauté c'est une manière de
considérer que enfin de d'agir et de
permettre à la au règlement de certains
conflits politiques vous êtes en train
de me dire c'est que il y aurait une
volonté qui est un gouvernement mondial
une forme de gouvernance mondiale c'est
pas et l'Église c'est ça l'Église ne dit
pas qu'elle forme doit revêtir ce
gouvernement mais en tout cas qu'il doit
y avoir une gouvernance mondiale qui qui
permette une plus grande unité entre les
peuples mais pour en revenir à la
question des migrants les conférences
épiscopales ont beaucoup plus de poids
en Afrique comme vous l'avez dit Madame
l'ambassadrice puisque au moment de la
chute de Mobutu c'est c'est la
conférence de ces piscopathe qui a tenu
le Zaïre il y a eu la même chose au
Bénin il y a eu la même chose dans un
certain nombre d'États et ça ça
permettrait peut-être dans l'avenir aux
évêques d'empêcher la malcouvernance et
donc dans ces cas-là d'empêcher les
migration vers l'Europe mais bien sûr
c'est donc exactement
je l'avais pressenti donc on peut avoir
foi justement dans les ces nouvelles
églises qui ne sont pas seulement des
dispensateurs de prêtres lorsque les
prêtres français partent même en
vacances on retraite vous voyez il y a
quelque chose de paradoxal parce que
d'un côté on est un peu contre
l'ingérence du pape François dans les
questions politiques et de l'autre on
met en avant les figures épiscopales qui
s'investissent quand il y a des crises
politiques dans leur pays et donc je
veux dire on est toujours dans ce dans
cet ambivalence de de l'accueil du
message de l'église pour aller dans
votre sens de tête de question la
première c'est que effectivement il y a
une conférence d'évêque en tous les cas
qui a été déterminant dans l'histoire en
Europe c'était en Pologne puisque il n'y
avait plus de nations polonaise et
finalement ça a été
l'église de Pologne en particulier ces
chefs et ses princes qui se prince de
l'église je pense cardial
adamsovie qui ont été l'incarnation de
la nation polonaise notamment à un
moment
la question également peut-être même
dans l'histoire de France
c'est même les prémices de avant le
baptême de Clovis c'est les évêques qui
jouent un rôle politique à un moment où
il y a un état de déréction dans le pays
mais qui pourtant ou alors qu'on est en
train d'évoquer l'oeuvre d'Orient
vraiment Seigneur gold niche à l'antenne
c'est cette
c'est le fait de ne plus vouloir porter
le fardeau politique qui va faire que on
va se tourner vers un chef de guerre qui
est Clovis mais vous savez dans
l'histoire de de
notre humanité du monde de l'église etc
vous avez des figures chrétiennes
extrêmement fortes qui se sont toujours
impliqués dans le bien de la cité vous
évoquez les conférences des évêques avec
des évêques qui prennent parfois le
relais d'un pouvoir politique défaillant
défaillant mais vous avez notamment en
Centrafrique d'ailleurs avec le
l'archevêque de Bangui qui a été nommé
créé cardinal et mais combien de
chrétiens laïques ont pris leur part
dans l'oeuvre politique pour justement
participer deux par leur foi au bien de
la cité et donc ces exemples-là existent
et même c'est en Afrique qui a eu un
chef d'État à la baisse super Yulu qui a
été premier président du Congo le neutre
un Congo Brazza
participer à la débilité des Templiers
c'est la conclusion de la messe vous
voyez que la communion n'a pas pris
beaucoup de plus de temps que dans une
messe ordinaire vous alliez parfaitement
raison
ils avaient de temps des règles aussi
d'où mais c'est pour ça que vous êtes là
c'est votre habitude de ces grands
rassemblements on écoute le canal à
Laveline
comment vous dire merci
les mots ne suffiront pas à vous
exprimer
l'immense reconnaissance qui monte de
nos cœurs au soir de cette inoubliable
journée
attendez
je n'ai fait que commencer
[Applaudissements]
déjà hier soir quand dès votre arrivée
vous êtes monté à Notre-Dame de la Gare
pour faire comme nous les Marseillais
quand nous menton confier nos vies à la
Vierge Marie déjà par ce geste vous avez
été baptisé marseillais
et puis
et puis quand on peut avant le coucher
du soleil vous avez pris ce moment de
recueillement avec tous les responsables
religieux de notre ville en hommage aux
migrants qui cherchaient l'espérance et
non trouvé que l'indifférence et
finalement la mort dans ce grand
cimetière qui est devenu notre mère là
chère pape François nous avons compris
que sans avoir besoin de faire le tour
de la France vous vouliez attirer les
regards de tout notre pays vers cette
Méditerranée et éveiller nos consciences
à la responsabilité qui est la nôtre par
rapport à cet espace qui fait partie de
notre histoire et de notre géographie
ce matin
ce matin après s'être allé rencontrer
des personnes en grande précarité dans
le quartier de Saint-Laurent sans doute
l'un des plus pauvres de France vous
avez rejoint les évêques les jeunes le
président de la République française et
toutes les personnalités engagées
concrètement au service de la paix en
Méditerranée vous avez encouragé nos
églises des cinq rives à continuer ce
travail de concertation commençait à
Bari puis à Florence et poursuivi ici à
Marseille merci très sympa pour vos
paroles fortes et courageuses
et ce soir
dans ce stade
quelle belle célébration et quelle
ambiance
un pape dans un stade ça s'est déjà vu
mais un pape au stade Vélodrome ça ne
s'était jamais vu
à demain
en venant ici dans cet enceinte c'est
comme si vous étiez allé chez chacun des
Marseillais comme à la maison
si vous saviez comme nous en sommes
fiers et heureux je crois que ce soir
même la Bonne Mère à la larme à l'oeil
et nous
et nous on vous accueillant pour la
première fois pour une messe en France
nous nous sentons encore une fois comme
on dit ici à jamais les premiers
Gratier Santo padre Marseille et avec
elle toute la France n'oubliera jamais
l'immense cadeau que vous nous avez fait
Santo padre
et c'est à tenait
non d'identité
[Applaudissements]
la traduction c'est ce qu'on a entendu
depuis le début nous n'oublierons pas de
prier pour vous
à l'issue d'une rencontre prier pour moi
qu'est-ce qu'on est en train de voir là
c'est un calice et alors je vous avoue
que j'ai je pense que c'est un cadeau du
pape François au cardinal à ville pour
le remercier de son accueil un calice
pour célébrer la messe évidemment mais
il va y avoir un mot de conclusion du
père avant la bénédiction finale je
pense
frères et sœurs pour votre présence et
pour votre prière merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour l'accueil que j'ai reçu mais aussi
tout le travail qui était fondament pour
les préparatifs
je vous remercie le président de la
République
tous les Français toutes les Françaises
tout à la caisse à Mercedes
marseillaise avec toutes ces communautés
de paroisses et de sécurité religieux
avec tous ces instituts
au sacré-cœur de Jésus
pendant une épidémie de peste
de Dieu
même en cette période d'épidémie
d'indifférence merci
pour votre service
[Applaudissements]
déterminez qui est témoignage
de la proximité de la compassion du
Seigneur
[Applaudissements]
survé 2016
qui ont lieu sur le sol français et
partout dans le monde
dévastées par la guerre
surtout pour le peuple craignant
malades les enfants les personnes âgées
[Applaudissements]
qui sont la mémoire de la civilisation à
une pensée surtout pour les personnes en
difficulté
tous les travailleurs de cette vie
le premier
ouvrier de la France
que la dignité des travailleurs s'a
toujours respecté et protégé
pour moi ce travail pas facile merci
comment faire
avec vous
quel est le nom du Seigneur soit béni
dans ce coup et dans les noms du
Seigneur
que Dieu tout puissant vous bénisse les
pins les fils Saint-Esprit
[Musique]
il y a pas plus de traditionnels comme
Jean Marielle pour finir une célébration
que le chant qui est repris
traditionnellement à Lourdes et que tous
les catholiques français connaissent
lourdes qui a été une ville qui a été
souvent visitée par le prince
d'écesseurs les prédécesseurs de du pape
François de visite de Jean-Paul II 83
2004 et puis le pape Benoît XVI c'était
en 2008
peut-être un commentaire sur ces mots à
la fois du cardinal à Laveline et du
pape François on en parlait hier
Elisabeth le temps de l'aigle
effectivement les victimes des attentats
terroristes de Nice notamment
explicitement ont été ont été évoqués on
lisait hier à Marseille aussi avait été
touché par
l'attentat à la gare Saint-Charles avec
deux jeunes filles qui avaient été
assassinées puis deuxième attentat à
Nice dans la basilique la basilique
Notre-Dame
je crois
que voilà ça n'a pas été s'il y avait
une interrogation hier sur cette entre
guillemets omission non il n'y a pas de
mission je dirais référence à Nice
compte tenu de l'ampleur et enfin du
drame énorme que ça a été et condamne
parallèlement tous les terroristes
oui c'est moi ça me surprend pas qu'il
l'évoque effectivement parce que les
attentats de Nice avaient une vraie
répercussion sur tout le territoire
français
et puis il y avait eu quand même la
vague du 14 juillet et puis ensuite
l'attentat dans l'église Notre-Dame de
les deux personnes trois personnes trois
personnes tu es tu es au couteau et donc
voilà mais pour moi
ça ne me surprend pas et et qui que le
papi fait référence et salut les
autorités notamment l'évêque de Nice
la Grande Peur soyons clairs c'est que
des migrants soient à l'origine
d'attentat je rappelle quand même que le
tueur présumé de Samuel Paty avait
obtenu un titre de séjour grâce à la
CNDA
donc quand national a droit des élèves
c'est ça donc ce sont quand même des
sujets extrêmement
périlleux il y a toujours la menace
terroriste et souvent une menace exogène
qui vise l'Occident et cette menace
malheureusement par trop souvent de
certaines rives de la Méditerranée alors
c'est pas toujours le cas parce que il y
a parfois des Français et dans les dans
les auteurs et même si à Nice notamment
dans le nord du deuxième attentat c'est
un migrant en situation irrégulière qui
venait d'arriver qui avait commis qui
avait commis l'attentat et qu'il y en
avait également dans les auteurs de des
attentats de Paris de 2015 quand le pape
fait référence à l'épidémie de
l'indifférence à quoi fait-il référence
précisément
je pense enfin je j'ai pas tous les
discours en tête évidemment mais il me
semble que c'est un c'est un point qui
est récurrent chez le pape François que
de pointer l'indifférence face à toute
forme de pauvreté et régulièrement je
cet indifférence on peut la mettre en
regard de l'individualisme qu'il pointe
beaucoup dans nos sociétés et donc pour
lui c'est une manière de de
véritablement bousculer les consciences
toute souffrance doit être pensée pan
doit être pensé par
tous ceux qui qui constatent ces
souffrances on ne doit pas simplement
avoir des beaux discours mais prendre en
charge toutes les souffrances qui
existent dans notre monde et le pape
vient souvent critiquer soit
l'individualisme soit l'indifférence par
rapport à toute forme de pauvreté de
souffrance
si je peux compléter ce que vous dites
qui est parfaitement juste
la mondialisation de l'indifférence
c'est une expression qu'il a emploie dès
et il l'a couple toujours je veux dire
avec cette cette individualisme qui est
en train de dévorer si je puis dire le
sentiment de la cité de la communauté
d'où cette nécessité de cette effort de
la fraternité dont il a parlé dont il a
parlé
tout à l'heure et puis peut-être un
autre point moi dans l'épidémie
évidemment comme moi j'étais j'ai vécu
la pandémie à Rome je veux dire au
Vatican il y a eu comme dans ce dans ce
moment de désarroi ou la voix du pape je
veux dire accompagner tous les jours par
la messe du matin qu'il avait ouvert
elle allait se priver qu'il avait ouvert
au monde entier il y avait aussi il y a
eu aussi ce dire ces paroles très fortes
c'est que un nous sommes tous dans le
même bateau et nous étions tous dans le
même bateau et nous n'en sortirons
qu'ensemble voilà et nous en sortirons
soit meilleur soit pire
carrefour de civilisation c'est la barre
de Saint-Pierre
alors la barque de Saint-Pierre en tous
les cas le pape lui a quitté le vélo de
Rome on va laisser vivre un petit peu
ces instants avec l'Alléluia de Haendel
qui interprété dans les travaux du vélo
de Rome
[Applaudissements]
avant d'aller rejoindre tout à l'heure
dans un instant Timothée et sur place
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Timothée délaime et dans les travées du
stade Vélodrome alors que Jean-Marie
guesnoy qu'on va rejoindre dans quelques
instants lui est déjà à l'aéroport de
Marignane où est attendu le pape
François avant de repartir vers Rome
Timothée vous êtes avec des fidèles qui
ont assisté comme vous à cette messe à
cette première à cette seule messe du
pape François sur le sol français
oui tout à fait Vincent avec deux
fidèles qui sont venus voilà père et
fils qui sont venus assister à cette à
cette baisse du pape François on a senti
une grande ferveur une atmosphère très
très brillante pendant cette messe c'est
quelque chose que vous avez ressenti
également
parce que j'ai trouvé exceptionnel c'est
que c'était une messe où il y avait
effectivement beaucoup de ferveur mais
aussi une masse très simple un peu comme
toutes les messes comme si le pape
François se mettait à notre à notre
hauteur c'était très émouvant qu'est-ce
que vous avez ressenti que vous avez vu
le pape François le Souverain Pontife
pénétrer dans dans ce stade Vélodrome là
on a été transporté en faisant partie de
cette grande foule qui était
complètement prise par l'émotion de voir
le pape c'est quelque chose qu'on avait
déjà vu au JMJ et là c'était vraiment
vraiment quelque chose de de
particulièrement poignant de voir ça a
répété mais au niveau local chez nous à
Marseille ici du coup de voir cette
ferveur populaire toujours présente sur
notre territoire c'est quelque chose
dont vous parliez dans votre dans votre
entourage vous me disiez que vous
habitez à Marseille la venue du Pape
Françoise quelque chose dont on parle
depuis longtemps on a on a pris ses
places on a pris ses billets depuis
longtemps on a pris le on a pris
rendez-vous ce weekend oui bien sûr ben
la dernière fois qu'un pape est venu à
Marseille c'était il y a 500 ans 500 ans
ouais donc voilà et puis au-delà de
prendre ses places je pense que c'est
tout le tout le peuple de Marseille qui
s'est mobilisé pour préparer cet
événement
je crois qu'il y a eu près de 3000
bénévoles qui se sont mobilisés pour
faire en sorte que tout se passe bien
et ça aussi c'est magnifique toute cette
ferveur tout ce monde 50 60 000
personnes 57000 précisément présents
aujourd'hui c'est le signe selon vous de
cette vitalité de l'Église de France
aujourd'hui malgré malgré les crises
tout à fait je pense que la spiritualité
c'est un sujet qui continue d'intéresser
on a vu les personnalités comme Gad
Elmaleh par exemple qui venaient sur qui
venait parler de sur ces thèmes là alors
qu'on les y attendait pas du tout et
c'est quelque chose qui qui peut
surprendre mais qui montre en fait que
vraiment chez les personnes auxquelles
on s'attend pas on peut trouver cette
cet élan vers la foi donc tout à fait
c'est un signe d'espérance je pense un
moment j'imagine que vous vous n'êtes
pas prêt d'oublier en tout cas bah c'est
certain et puis quand on dit que quand
on est face à une église qui est un peu
malade c'est vrai on est aussi face à
une église qui est pleine d'espérance et
et quand quand la poisse c'est c'est
l'amour mais en fait l'amour résiste à
tout et l'amour emportera tout et tout
le temps le cardinal architecte de
Marseille disait au pape François vous
avez été baptisé marseillais ce week-end
c'est un sentiment que vous partagez il
a été baptisé Marseille ce weekend le
bac français
une personnalité incroyable c'est
quelqu'un qui est hyper attachant hyper
proche de ses de son peuple et tout le
monde le reconnaît c'est on peut pas
rester indifférent face à face à un tel
archevêque
sur cette question effectivement où est
le il a vraiment loin le bug François il
lui a donné sa bénédiction pour faire
partie du peuple marseillais qui a qu'il
a beaucoup touché je pense en venant ici
spécialement pour parler de de ces
sujets autour de la Méditerranée qui est
vraiment ancrée dans l'histoire de
Marseille cette visite pontificale à
Marseille chez vous c'est quelque chose
qui va qui va porter des fruits dans les
semaines dans les années à venir à
Marseille et partout en France vous
pensez
qu'on reçoit une telle dose d'esprit
sain forcément ça laisse pas
complètement indifférent donc oui je
pense que ça va raviver la foi des
Marseillais qui reste un territoire à
conquérir pour pour la poire de manière
générale pas forcément que pour les
catholiques mais pour tous les croyants
musulmans juifs chrétiens voilà merci
beaucoup pour votre pour votre
témoignage voilà Vincent pour ces deux
fidèles donc qui ont insisté à la messe
présidée par le pape François et il
semble que maintenant ce soit le groupe
de pas pouvoir je glorieuses qui soit en
train et bien de mettre l'ambiance dans
ce dans ce stade et qui va maintenant se
vider petit à petit même si à vue d'oeil
c'est pas flagrant
effectivement on ne voit effectivement
encore du monde dans les travées
derrière vous et merci beaucoup pour
pour ces témoignages merci beaucoup pour
cette réaction à chaude c'est de ces
fidèles peut-être un commentaire père
burgien notamment ce père de famille qui
disait que effectivement cette visite
fait du bien à un moment où
on est dans une église un peu blessée je
voudrais souligner deux choses la
première c'est qu'effectivement le rôle
du pape ou d'un évêque d'ailleurs et
toujours de de
réconforter la foi de ses frères et donc
à partir du moment en 1986
on vient se laisser fortifier dans la
foi et la foi vous savez elle est jamais
acquise une fois pour toute et on a
toujours besoin de se laisser enseigner
fortifier à la fois par le moment où ça
peut la fourra pour un homme de foi et
votre cas ça peut ça peut saphir même
pour un prêtre
il peut y avoir des moments de désert
des moments de doute et justement le
fait de s'appuyer sur la foi de l'Église
vous savez quand je célèbre la messe le
dimanche et j'aime le rappeler au
chrétiens aux paroissiens qui sont là
par exemple quand on proclame le credo
c'est pas je proclame pas le credo du
père burgien je proclame la foi de
l'Église c'est celle-là sur laquelle je
m'appuie et quand j'ai moi-même des
questions et des doutes et bien je
m'appuie sur la foi de mes frères et de
voir une assemblée qui est là sa
fortifie à la fois le pasteur et à la
fois le peuple et donc se laisser
enseigner par le pape et ces images que
l'on a vu de communion de ferveur etc
face comme je le disais tout à l'heure à
une institution qui est parfois un peu
fragile ou fragilisée et bien ça
réconforte aussi de devoir qu'on est pas
seul et puis la deuxième chose que que
je voulais les souligner aussi c'est que
moi je suis touché de voir l'effort des
chrétiens qui qui ont participé à cet
événement le père de famille a évoqué le
nombre de bénévoles qui ont donné un
coup de main pour les questions de
sécurité pour l'organisation etc mais
aussi il faut il faut se rendre compte
et je suis pas sûr que les les ceux qui
nous regardent en ce moment se rendent
compte du tout ces pèlerins qui sont
venus à Marseille le temps qu'il a fallu
le temps d'attendre les questions de
sécurité surtout dans le dans le
contexte sécurité dans lequel on est etc
et en fait tous ces gens ont pris de
leur peine de leur effort de leur temps
pour venir participer à cette
Eucharistie et ça aussi même si c'est un
peu caché c'est extrêmement touchant
d'en prendre conscience
vous sentez renforcer ce soir par ce que
vous avez vu ce que vous avez entendu ce
que vous avez vécu ici même oui parce
que déjà une messe avec le Saint Père
qu'on la regarde derrière un écran ou ou
qu'on y assiste c'est toujours un
événement fort et moi même comme prêtre
je me sens conforté par ce message et et
je peux vous dire une chose c'est que je
me sens conforté aussi par une forme de
courage parce que le pape François dans
l'avion la redit il demandait à l'Esprit
Saint d'avoir le courage d'interpeller
notre société notre monde sur les sujets
les plus forts et je trouve aujourd'hui
le plus courageux de votre point de vue
déjà en venant parce qu'en fait
c'était pas c'était pas c'était pas
gagné que le pape François Vienne
clôturer c'est ses journées de la
Méditerranée et moi je trouve qu'il a
été courageux et comme je l'ai dit au
début de
l'Eucharistie au début du temps je
trouve qu'il a été très courageux ce
matin devant les évêques et devant le
pouvoir politique de rappeler que oui il
y a la migration mais en fait toute
forme de fragilité toute forme de
pauvreté toute forme de souffrance
réclame notre compassion et notre
engagement sur des sujets cruciaux tels
que l'euthanasie encore une fois il y a
un projet de loi en France dramatique
sur cette question et donc là aussi le
pape François a eu des mots très
courageux et très clair pour interpeller
le pouvoir politique on va essayer de
retrouver de retourner à Marseille avoir
voir Timothée délai
sur cette épidémie de l'indifférence de
votre point de vue
je vous attendais vous ayez un discours
très critique surtout ce qu'on a pu
entendre depuis depuis
hier sur skylie le pape François mais
vous n'y est qui est cette épidémie là
la différence au contraire et je trouve
que le pape François de très belles
paroles quant aux migrants parce que le
migrant est un être déraciné
donc justement on le en même temps le
pape rappelle la sonde son individu son
individuelles sont le fait que son être
c'est un être humain et en même temps le
fait qu'il soit déraciné affaibli le
migrant et c'est à dire qu'il le sort de
sa nation et ne sort de sa communauté
donc la dignité humaine dont parle pas
pour le migrant et bien en même temps
quand le sort de son pays ça le
fragilise et c'est ça et c'est pour cela
que le pape nous appelle avoir un regard
éminemment fraternel envers le migrant
mais tout ce qui a dit le Pape et
d'ailleurs ce que vous disiez monsieur
Labbé ça s'appelle la communion des
saints le principe des raffermi
lorsqu'on est en présence de d'autres
catholiques et là le pape s'est exprimé
en tant que Vicaire du Christ il
n'empêche justement que le pape n'est
Maker que lorsqu'il parle des sujets
éminemment catholiques et lorsqu'il ne
fait pas de discrétion
de 5000 personnes devant lui il ne reste
plus que les douze apôtres qui ne
comprennent pas grand chose et à qui il
dit voulez-vous partir vous aussi
l'église n'est pas là pour avoir un
discours efficace pour être d'abord
entendu ou écouter elle est là pour
proclamer quelque chose qui n'est pas
forcément reçu on va retrouver
Timothée délai mais avant Jean-Marie
guesnoy qui est à l'aéroport de
Marignane qui attend le pape on a vu
également le convoi partir s'élancer sur
les avenues de Marseille bonjour
Jean-Marie merci beaucoup d'avoir été en
direct avec nous tout au long de cette
de ce voyage qu'est-ce que vous retenez
d'abord de ce que l'on a entendu de ce
que l'on a vu
ici au Vélodrome et de façon générale ce
que vous retenez de ce voyage
d'abord je vous préviens que je suis
dans le bus qui va nous mener à l'avion
du pape donc ça va peut-être bouger
l'image mais c'est la vie du reportage
avec tous les journalistes on faisait un
grand bus en 70 et là on veut nous
conduire dans l'avion même en général on
y est une heure 45 minutes une heure
avant lui même peut-être moins dans ce
cas-là ce que je retiens de ce voyage en
tout cas c'est d'abord
l'intensité on s'attendait un voyage un
vrai faux voyage du pape en France en
fait c'est un vrai voyage non pas par le
protocole mais par l'intensité de ce que
le Pape a pu dire et l'intensité du cœur
il y a eu tout à l'heure dans le stade
du Vélodrome un moment extraordinaire de
communion qui était
pastis il s'est passé quelque chose
quand le Pape a dit bonjour la France il
a en quelque sorte chercher à se
réconcilier avec cette France qu'il n'a
pas voulu visiter de façon officielle
mais qu'il a visité d'une certaine
manière avec son cœur je crois que ça a
marché ça a touché vraiment les gens et
ainsi de suite hier soir l'arrivée à
Marseille c'était aussi le même de la
même sève le cœur
la présence
ça c'est le premier point le deuxième
point ce sont donc premier point c'est
c'est la forme ce voyage le style de ce
voyage qui est effectivement réussi on
peut pas dire le contraire sur le fond
maintenant le message il est extrêmement
exigeant ce matin le discours du Cap
devant les rencontres méditerranéennes
donc ce groupe d'évêque réunit de toutes
les retours méditerranéens pour évoquer
les différents problèmes dont celui de
la migration a été une leçon en quelque
sorte sur l'importance pour le pape
d'accueillir les les personnes
migrantes et il a une nouvelle fois
vraiment assez fortement sur le sujet ça
ne paiera pas tout le monde on verra si
effectivement ce message sera reçu par
reçu en tout cas le papa redit de façon
très ferme la nécessité pour lui
d'accueillir il a même été plus loin en
disant les générations futures nous
remercieront d'avoir en quelque sorte
ouvert les frontières je ne sais pas
c'est tout le monde est d'accord sur ce
point en tout cas il a critiqué il a il
a il a répondu à ceux qui veulent
arrêter le flux migratoire lui a dit non
ce n'est pas la bonne méthode donc ça
c'est un message très exigeant on l'a
retrouvé aussi pendant le la messe c'est
une autre forme mais c'est quand même
une Mélie donc un commentaire d'évangile
il est pas question pour le fait de
faire de la politique mais il a glissé
quand même quelques phrases notamment
comparant la défense de la vie qui est
une tradition dans l'Église catholique
la défense des enfants
non cornés donc l'avortement et puis
contre l'avortement évidemment mais
mettons sur le même plan la défense de
la vie
pour les embryons et il le dit dans le
texte les réfugiés il met sur le même
plan défense de la vie
disons classique ce qu'on en connaissait
dans l'église
contre le tanaisie contre l'avortement
et il le met son même plan avec la
défense des personnes libérées des
personnes qui sont en souffrance aussi
une traditions
courage les chrétiens à ouvrir
immédiatement leur porte à quelqu'un qui
frappe parce qu'il est dans le besoin ça
fait partie du message biblique c'est
pas seulement chrétien c'est aussi c'est
tout la tradition biblique et celle de
l'Évangile évidemment donc on a un
voyage
surprenant
belle surprise parce que le pape il a
parlé un peu français il a su parler au
cœur de la France en la prenant
peut-être pas en lieu on lui redisant
l'importance au fond du message
chrétien le cœur l'homélie de tout à
l'heure était très frappante de ce point
de vue là
et
à côté de ce sourire en quelque sorte il
y a un message très très net très fort
en direction des hommes politiques sur
la question des migrations mais pas
seulement des responsables français
puisqu'il l'a aussi mis dans la balance
l'importance pour l'institution
européenne de prendre en main ce sujet
d'immigration on sait parler contacts
qu'on a pu avoir avec
la rencontre que la question la famille
n'a pas été très discutée apparemment
lors de leur rencontre entre le
Président de la République française un
peu parlé mais sans plus d'après le
savoir
mais là aussi le Pape a été net il a
toujours dit qu'il était contre toute
forme de législation qui conduirait
d'une façon ou d'une autre à permettre à
quelqu'un de se donner la mort
merci Jean-Marie juste une dernière
question vous allez prendre l'avion avec
le Pape
généralement il prend il parle en train
de rouler il peut il vient voir les
journalistes quelle question vous
aimeriez vous allez lui poser
ah non mais ça c'est top secret je vais
pas vous dire les questions qu'on va
poser au pape maintenant faut pas
exagérer ce serait une faute
professionnelle de patenter
[Musique]
nous en saurons plus à l'arrivée à Rome
il sera il sera là
dans une demi-heure on arrive avant on a
21h50
21h je crois donc on en sera plus à ce
moment-là et on se fera fort de le de
l'écrire sur le site du Figaro pour que
ça se trouve dès ce soir en fin de
soirée et évidemment demain matin et
c'est ça effectivement à lire et à
suivre justement sur le site du Figaro à
partir de ce soir donc vous restez bien
arrivé comme vous l'êtes actuellement
sur le site du Figaro merci beaucoup
Jean-Marie je signale votre dernier
livre vous viendrez nous en parler plus
longuement au plateau même si vous
l'avez déjà fait dans l'émission de
Jelly Bastié cette semaine pape François
à la révolution c'est chez Gallimard
c'est un livre absolument passionnant et
effectivement qui nous permet de rentrer
dans la tête du pape François pour
reprendre l'expression du père Burga à
l'instant et en tous les cas avec les
les regards de l'Église c'est un livre
extrêmement profond et très documenté et
extrêmement bien écrit
effectivement je devais ça à la
confraternité mais je devais ça
également à la vérité c'est le livre que
vous devez lire actuellement sur le sur
le pape François et c'est aux éditions
Gallimard bon voyage merci beaucoup
Jean-Marie merci Vincent à bientôt au
revoir Jean-Marie Le guesnoy je pense
est je l'espère en tous les cas nominés
au prix du journaliste religieux le plus
geek de Paris
justement sur cette question des
générations futures on va y revenir mais
je voudrais qu'on aille puisqu'on avait
des images du vélo de Rome à Marseille
et on reviendra peut-être sur une image
qu'on a que les internautes ont
peut-être pas vu bien sûr Philippe
Fontana je ne vous empêcherai pas d'y
revenir mais on va retrouver Timothée
d'Hélène lui qui est dans les travers du
Stade Vélodrome derrière cette tribune
Jean Bouin et Virage Sud que nous voyons
et qui était également avec une personne
qui a participé visiblement à la messe
du pape François
oui Vincent tout à fait avec une fidèle
qui est venue et qui est venue en
famille avec votre mari avec vos enfants
pour vous c'était important de
d'assister à cette messe du pape
François tous ensemble en famille
c'était formidable et très important
pour partager et surtout avec les
enfants pour leur montrer qu'on peut
aller au stade Vélodrome autrement que
pour voir des matchs de rugby qui sont
même s'ils sont des bonnes ambiances on
peut aussi aller au Vélodrome et voir le
pape et être et être en folie en joie et
vous me disiez d'ailleurs que cela fait
plus de six mois que vous avez réservé
les billets pour vous c'est tout un
rendez-vous incontournable à ne pas
manquer oui c'était un grand événement à
Marseille très bien organisé du reste à
travers les paroisses et effectivement
il peut aller s'y prendre assez tôt pour
avoir des places et puis on a eu la
chance d'être extrêmement bien placé
donc c'était super justement comment
est-ce que vous avez vécu cette messe
pardon comment est-ce que c'est vrai
qu'on s'entend pas très bien je
le précise pour vous qui êtes en plateau
il y a beaucoup de bruit ici beaucoup de
ferveur donc on essaye de s'entendre je
vous demandais comment est-ce que vous
avez vécu cette messe ont souligné tout
à l'heure l'atmosphère très friante
je crois que j'ai reçu
100% le message du pape et mon cœur a
tressailli et
Monseigneur Aveline a conclu en disant
que Notre Dame de la Garde avait eu sans
doute avait eu l'alarme à l'oeil et moi
aussi j'ai eu l'alarme à l'oeil et très
très heureuse de vivre ce moment de
communion intense avec des messages
extrêmement forts on en a beaucoup parlé
de ces messages
politiques mais pas que des messages
d'accueil d'ouverture de fraternité et
ça fait beaucoup de bien m'entendre des
messages de fraternité qu'allez-vous
retenir de ces deux jours passés par le
pape François à Marseille
l'accueil transforme en nous
vivons vivons notre foi au quotidien et
sachant ça sur nous ouvrir aujourd'hui
il y avait également un certain nombre
de représentants politiques Emmanuel
Macron était présent dans le stade
Gérald Darmanin également qu'est-ce que
cela vous inspire
alors très honnêtement
c'est très bien aussi qu'ils sont venus
mais mais finalement il n'était pas les
personnages clés de la journée et je
crois qu'on en a beaucoup parlé mais
peut-être voilà moi je les considère
comme les représentants du pouvoir
temporel ils sont venus en tant que chef
d'État et de gouvernement sans doute
saluer un autre chef d'État mais
aujourd'hui il n'était pas il était pas
au centre du jeu j'espère qu'ils auront
été touchés par le message et que la
grâce de l'instant les aidera dans le
dans leur quotidien merci beaucoup pour
votre témoignage bonne avançons alors
que la fête se poursuit ici au stade
Vélodrome vous les entendez derrière moi
les champs qui sont en train de
continuer de retentir dans ce stade le
stade qui pour le coup était en train de
se de se remplir pour le coup maintenant
et cela se voit à vue d'œil
je sais pas si ça se remplit ou si ça se
vide
de se vider pardon bien sûr
bon ben justement vous vous qui ne se
vide pas complètement parce qu'on sera
heureux d'avoir des témoignages de
fidèle tout à l'heure on voyait
également
d'autres d'autres banderoles et
notamment une qui vous a qui vous a
touché Philippe fontaine vous connaissez
mon amour pour l'Algérie Notre-Dame de
Santa Cruz à Oran
et c'est bien pour ça que je partage une
certaine inquiétude tout au long de
notre rendez-vous aujourd'hui je vous ai
parlé des Arméniens au début ce peuple
qui est en train de d'être chassé aucune
allusion aucune allusion alors que alors
que Marseille est comme disait le
président de la République comme dans sa
campagne électorale c'est Marseille
c'est une terre aussi d'Armagnac il y a
80 000 Arméniens rien
est-ce que le pape je le disais mais je
le redis est-ce que le pape va faire
pression sur l'Union européenne pour
qu'elle interrompre ses contrats gaziers
avec les servagiants mais est-ce que
c'est le rôle du pape Elizabeth de faire
le pape c'est à parler de la parler de
Dieu de duo Karaba et de l'Arménie je
veux dire dans son homélie juste avant
que c'est suffit d'aller regarder sur ma
ticket de news vous verrez me dire donc
il a pas zappé le sujet si je puis dire
ensuite où nous sommes bien d'accord que
le monde n'a pas été prononcé
aujourd'hui tout à fait ensuite je
reviens sur notre âme mais pardon est-ce
que il est envisageable que le pape sans
l'évoquer
face pression ou en tout cas joue un
rôle sur ce sur ce conflit
si je dirais ça c'est la diplomatisation
tu veux dire avec avec
son pouvoir et ses limites je veux dire
la diplomatie vaticale on l'a déjà dit
JRC à diplomatie de la parole c'est la
diplomatie de la discrétion lire de la
discrétion on fait pas des coups qu'on
annonce c'est pas du tout ça la grande
différence peut-être avec le politique
ou une certaine façon de faire la
politique on n'est pas du tout dans la
politique on est dans la politique de la
discrétion on est souvent dans la
politique des petits pas et évidemment
je veux dire avec les résultats
qui peuvent être totalement ténus ou qui
peuvent être inexistants et ça c'est
bien la définition d'un pouvoir
d'influence et ça l'aide d'autant plus
je le répète à un moment où la règle de
droit international est en train d'être
bafoué et où les institutions de
régulation justement pour favoriser la
paix sont aujourd'hui paralysés la voix
du pape cette voix d'influence pouvoir
d'influence il pèse d'autant plus qui
peut justement se traduit ensuite au
sein de la commune dans les institutions
internationales qui étaient qui sont là
pour
pour prévenir les conflits et gérer la
paix c'est à dire très concrètement les
Nations Unies le Conseil de sécurité
fallait hors celle-ci vous voyez bien
non seulement sont à la peine mais sont
entrés dans un processus de d'élitement
et qui est aussi et qui peut menacer
aussi l'Europe si vous voulez c'est à
dire le fait de faire sauter je le
disais cette barrière de la règle de la
règle de droit qui fonde l'humanisme
d'ailleurs le seul
à des observateurs tantales l'ONU qu'au
Conseil de l'Europe mais bien sûr quelle
l'UNESCO mais bien sûr et c'est vrai que
la diplomatie française est très proche
de la diplomatie du Saint Siège
c'est-à-dire une défense de la paix y
compris
on va en reparler on a un prêtre en
plateau on a une religieuse également en
duplex elle est avec Timothée d'Hélène à
dans les stravés du Stade Vélodrome
Timothée cette religieuse appartient à
une communauté que je ne connaissais pas
jusqu'à présent mais effectivement on en
apprend tous les jours c'est la
communauté de prière du cœur de Jésus
exactement Vincent la communauté de
prière et du cœur de Jésus bonjour Ma
sœur merci d'être avec nous vous avez
accepté de venir témoigner parce que
vous me disiez que vous avez vécu une
messe particulièrement belle et
particulièrement forte qu'est-ce que
vous avez vécu pendant cette messe
moi je vécu vraiment
une joie inoubliable c'est unique
un union de prière avec notre Pape tous
les prêtres tous les évêques venant de
toute la Méditerranée c'est vraiment
exceptionnel exceptionnel et tous les
peuples marseillais moi je pense que il
était tous dans la joie aussi
d'accueillir notre Pape
de vivre ce moment unique
pour cette grande messe
autour de notre président aussi notre
mère de Marseille
c'est fantastique
Dieu pour ce cadeau qu'il nous donne
aujourd'hui quand c'est pas uniquement
aux chrétiens que le Seigneur a donné
cette formidable journée mais c'est à
tous les peuples marseillais il y a tous
les peuples français sans exception cela
fait 500 ans qu'un Pape n'était pas venu
à Marseille qu'est-ce que cela vous fait
d'avoir accueilli dans votre ville le
pape François pendant deux jours moi je
pense vraiment que c'est un cadeau
cadeau béni cadeau du ciel canaux de
cadeaux de Dieu
dans l'état
de santé qu'il vit aujourd'hui il a pu
nous offrir ce moment merveilleux
[Musique]
c'est fantastique c'est vraiment
c'est l'amour c'est l'amour de Dieu
c'est l'amour pour nous ses frères et
sœurs de venir jusqu'à nous à Marseille
pour vivre cette joie
cette joie cette fraternité
c'est un cadeau je remercie vivement
notre Pape s'il y avait peut-être une
image à retenir de ces deux jours de
visite du pape François à Marseille
laquelle serait-elle
c'est l'amitié
c'est l'amitié c'est la fraternité c'est
l'amour
[Musique]
vraiment ça c'est l'amour merci beaucoup
voilà Vincent pour ce pour ce témoignage
de cette religieuse qui a donc vécu
cette cette messe ici au stade Vélodrome
merci beaucoup Timothée merci pour ces
témoignages de cette religie de cette
religieuse alors que on voit encore les
fidèles quitter le vélo de Drôme le pape
François devrait lui décoller d'ici une
vingtaine de minutes de l'aéroport de
Marignane où nous serons en direct en
tous les cas nous aurons les images de
ce départ de cette cérémonie de départ
où est également où seront également
présents Brigitte et Emmanuel Macron une
question par rapport à
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure
Philippe Fontana effectivement cette
banderole de Santa Cruz qui est
l'évocation également de
Oran en Algérie et de la Vierge de Santa
Cruz qui est là-bas
la Méditerranée
on le dit un petit peu en entreprendre
ce qu'on entend depuis depuis hier c'est
un lieu parfois aussi de confrontation
un lieu de tension il n'y a pas
tellement d'endroits tranquille autour
de la Méditerranée c'est ce que disait
le cardinal haveline ce matin il y a des
antagonistes forts on a il y a une
histoire souvent d'affrontement que ce
soit les les croisades que ce soit
l'extension l'extension de l'Empire
ottoman que c'était avant les raids
barbaresque et puis ensuite la
colonisation la guerre d'Algérie et les
conflits encore actuels et malgré tout
c'était intéressant d'ailleurs
d'entendre le Monseigneur de moulin
Beaufort cité Giono qui parlait d'une
communion de la Méditerranée il y a des
quand on regarde un certain nombre
d'écrivains très antagoniste
qui ont célébré
la Méditerranée
et qui de toutes les tendances y compris
en France d'ailleurs il y a est-ce qu'il
y a pas cette effectivement là où le
pape a pour reprendre l'expression
d'Elisabeth le temps de hier quelque
chose de prophétique il touche quelque
chose quand même de profond dans cette
communion qu'il y a dans la Méditerranée
on dit on dit souvent que le Christ est
arrivé
sur les bords de la Méditerranée au
moment où le grec unifié la pensée et où
il y avait cette cette facilité de
communication entre toutes les peuples
de la Méditerranée donc c'est vrai qu'il
y a la Méditerranée est un berceau de
l'homme
la mer Méditerranée est un berceau des
civilisations et il y a cette communion
commune entre un méditerranéen du Nord
amène terrain du Sud à méditerranéens
des 5 rives comme disait le pape et le
cap d'avril et c'est peut-être de là que
viendra le
salut puisque on sait que y compris chez
les catholiques il faut d'abord beaucoup
souffert pour qu'il y ait une espérance
de celui qui se manifeste donc la
Méditerranée est aujourd'hui un calvaire
peut-être que de la Méditerranée viendra
le salut
une autre question qui est soulevée
alors
c'est cette question sur la sur la
pauvreté dans la discours du Pape
souvent il y a une dénonciation
on l'a pas trop entendu l'art de ce
discours peut-être qu'on entendra dans
l'avion du retour mais la dénonciation
du populisme souvent les les
parties 10 populistes
en tous les cas ont une partie de leur
électorat qui est un électorat populaire
et
qui a été un électorat qui souvent a
voté à gauche et puis qui s'est porté
sur ces parties soit d'extrême droite
soit sur des parties populaires et
précisément ce qui a fait basculer cet
électorat-là c'est la question la
question de l'immigration et la question
de la pauvreté en clair l'un des
arguments souvent c'est de dire mais
l'immigration
ceux qui ont sont victimes en tout cas
ceux qui la subissent sont pas les plus
riches mais les plus pauvres
oui les riches sont toujours dans des
ghettos c'est ce que
stigmatisme le pape mais la question de
l'Europe pourquoi était devenue si
égoïste et si individualiste parce qu'il
n'a plus aujourd'hui de figures
spirituelles marquantes
donc il n'y a plus cet entraînement du
peuple par l'élite et donc c'est vrai
que le rétrécissement se fait à tous les
niveaux il se fait matériellement il se
fait spirituellement et donc il y a
cette antagoniste qui est de plus en
plus fort et qui peuvent exploiter les
populistes
est-ce que quand cette forme de pauvreté
justement qui est quand même très forte
qui structure quand même des votes qui
sont massifs aujourd'hui et pas un
discours un peu oublié dans je dirais
pas de l'église parce que ça pas
tellement de sens mais en tout cas
dans un certain dans un certain
intelligent sia catholique aujourd'hui
si vous avez raison et d'ailleurs c'est
pour ça que je suis
je suis d'accord avec ce que Jean-Marie
guesnoy nous a dit tout à l'heure c'est
à dire que il a souligné l'importance du
discours du Pape en mettant sur un même
plan d'égalité la question migratoire la
défense de la vie à naître et la
question de l'euthanasie parce
qu'effectivement il faut le reconnaître
que chez catholique et une frange
importante du catholicisme on est
parfois plus enclin à défendre la
question de l'avortement et de
l'euthanasie et un peu moins sur les
questions de migration et donc là le
pape François a voulu bousculer
les mentalités catholiques sur cet
aspect aussi en leur appelant que la
défense de la vie se fait à tous ces
niveaux et pas simplement certains
niveaux sur lesquels on est parfois très
engagé ou très en vue je vous repose ma
question en période
est-ce que il y a toute une partie je
pose la question plus fortement
de l'ancien catholique y compris
qui veut s'ouvrir sur les questions de
migration mais qui ne méprise pas toute
cette partie de la population qui est
partie des plus modestes qui aujourd'hui
crie son exaspération facile
d'immigration oui sans doute parce que
parce que le catholicisme français
et aussi un catholicisme je vais
peut-être me faire taper dessus en me
disant mais c'est pas grave je pense que
c'est un catholicisme qui a pu se couper
d'une certaine frange de la population
de classe populaire on a parfois un
discours tellement intellectuel qu'en
fait on ne sait plus rejoindre une
certaine forme de pauvreté ou des
franges plus simples de la population et
donc il y a aussi une forme de fracture
qui est mise en avant là
une autre question qui est posée et ça
je voudrais vous la poser
comment le Saint-Siège
gère la montée en puissance de l'islam
fondamentaliste dans les pays où l'islam
et majoritaire et dans les pays où il ne
l'est pas
alors il se renvoie un peu toujours à ce
que j'ai dit je veux dire ce c'est à
dire
le dialogue le dialogue le dialogue et
le dialogue je veux dire n'est pas
unique une épingle uniquement je dirais
une utopie si vous voulez c'est parce
qu'il y a aussi le souci
d'apporter d'essayer de protéger les
minorithmes chrétiennes je répète je
répète quand même qu'il y a un chrétien
sur 7 dans le monde qui est persécuté et
donc ça par contre c'est une
responsabilité c'est une responsable je
crois géopolitique protestante a montré
que c'est même la minorité la plus
persécutée dans le monde
et donc il y a cette responsabilité
vis-à-vis de ces des minorités
chrétiennes qui fait que aussi le
discours public
il est complètement assourdi voire
inexistant je veux dire sur sur la
nature de de
ces régimes ou de oui de ces régimes
théocratie etc ça je crois que c'est
très mal compris je veux dire oui mais
enfin pourquoi vous vous ne vous ne
dénoncez pas le cas des ouigo etc mais
il y a ce souci aussi de veiller à dès
lors que l'on à ne pas sortir de cette
neutralité entre guillemets et d'essayer
de pousser ses pions je répète par de
la du compte des contacts de la
négociation
silencieuse mais des fois ça marche pas
du tout regardez le Nicaragua Nicaragua
on expulse
on expulsé le lion non son on est en
train d'expulser l'église ça ne marche
pas toujours et pourtant là c'est
vraiment l'église on ne parle pas de une
communauté on parle d'un os on parle des
Vêves etc et le discours est pareil
extrêmement
préoccupé mais sans aller à la rue à la
rupture ou à des prises de position très
fortes il y a le il y a le discours et
puis le dialogue parfois un peu
silencieux et caché et puis il y a des
gestes extrêmement forts pour le 10 pour
le discours pour le dialogue avec
l'islam par exemple il faut revenir au
voyage extrêmement important que le pape
François avait fait Abou Dhabi aux
Émirats arabes unis en 2019 de mémoire
et qui a été un voyage extrêmement
prophétique avec des discours et des
rencontres très claires et très
prophétiques là aussi et donc on voit
bien que le sans siège use de toutes les
armes diplomatiques parfois un dialogue
caché dans le dans les salons feutrés de
la diplomatie parfois par des voyages
extrêmement forts et symboliques que
fait la papauté
qui a une suite après un baril à la
suite à Bahreïn bon en quoi a consisté
en quoi
rédigé avec le grand imam de la mosquée
Lazare voilà alors avec cette difficulté
que d'un côté vous avez un chef de
l'Église et que de l'autre côté vous
avez un islam qui n'est pas
qui n'a pas de chef donc
là on est avec le monde sunnite si je
vais plus dire et quand il va Bagdad sur
les traces d'Abraham je répète premier
voyage après
après la pandémie il va rencontrer
Sistani l'imam Sistani cheat
la question je vous la pose à l'inverse
il y a eu un discours qui a été un
discours d'ouverture il faut s'ouvrir à
l'immigration c'est un dimension du
débat
dimension du débat politique savoir si
les étapes peuvent accueillir ou pas
mais il y a une autre question c'est que
souvent quand même
l'immigration et une immigration en tous
les cas aujourd'hui en France en Europe
l'immigration essentiellement musulmane
ce qui n'est pas le cas de tous les
musulmans enfin un truc il y a un
certain discours islamique qui est un
discours de conquête par rapport à ça
est-ce que
il est prudent à ce qu'il est sain de
dire d'ouvrir à tout à tout vent alors
qu'il y a cette crainte et ou de
culpabiliser comme ça a été fait hier
sur la crainte de l'invasion
ce qui était pas le cas du patch je
crois que c'était plutôt le gardien
d'Aveline oui c'est ça parce que il faut
bien voir que le pape les accents très
forts qu'il a mis sur la question de
l'immigration pendant ces deux jours
était une attention personnelle à ceux
qui meurent en Méditerranée et donc il
faut faire la distinction entre ceux qui
émigrent pour des raisons extrêmement
politiques et ceux qui migrent pour fuir
une situation de pauvreté chez eux et
donc je pense que le pape François fait
quand même une distinction subtile dans
ce dans dans l'attention que l'on doit
avoir aux situations des migrants ben
c'est une c'est une
la différence entre les deux et de plus
en plus ténus car en reprenant encore
une fois une jurisprudence de la CNDA
voyez que la France accordait l'asile à
une femme qui était mariée de force en
Afrique quand on sait que 30% des femmes
sont mariées de force en Afrique vous
voyez le nombre de personnes qui
pourraient recevoir l'asile en France
donc
la distinction est de plus en plus ténue
entre le droit d'asile dont l'Église
s'est fait le héros pendant des années
et sont dévoiement aujourd'hui et moi
j'aurais bien aimé même si c'est mon
sujet de prédilection que le pape en
parle en disant on ne pourra plus
accueillir des personnes pour des
raisons uniquement économiques
et son discours n'a rien à voir avec
celui du discours de du pape Jean-Paul
II ou Jean-Paul II parlait du phare des
nations ou Jean-Paul II expliquait que
l'État avait le droit de défendre ses
frontières ou Jean-Paul II avait le
verdier autour de Suède également oui
mais là
c'est un discours qui est constant dans
l'église le droit de rester le droit de
s'en aller mais il y a des papes qui
font qui mettent le halo dans une des
deux parties du discours alors ce qui
est vrai c'est que là c'était pas le
halo de de ce voyage de ce voyage là
on est en direct donc de Marignane 18h35
le pape devrait décoller d'ici une
dizaine de minutes et
transporter à bord de tous les cas
l'avion qui le transportera transportera
également à son bord sortant de
journalistes dont Jean-Marie guesnoy qui
je peut-être pourra lui poser comme au
retour de Lisbonne une question qui nous
la réponse
sera fera la une et en tous les cas ce
qui serait intéressant c'est d'avoir les
réponses du pape et en particulier sur
la question de l'immigration on a vu
également Gérald Darmanin sur place le
voyage à Marseille touche à sa fin sur
le plan sécurité ça a été en tous les
cas on n'a pas d'incidents qui sont
remontés ce qui différent de ce qui se
passe actuellement à Paris ou
apparemment les une voiture de police a
été attaquée à coup de barre de fer
comme vous pouvez le lire sur le site de
du Figaro lors de la manifestation
contre les violences policières entre
guillemets qui était organisé notamment
dans la capitale Gérard Darmanin qui
avait déployé d'ailleurs un dispositif
record pour
gérer cette manifestations de mémoire 30
000 policiers qui étaient déployés pour
ces manifestations
ici donc le à Marignane rien de tel tout
s'est passé en tous les cas en apparence
et aucune information pour l'instant on
est remonté
conformément à ce qui était prévu le
dispositif sécuritaire a fonctionné
peut-être que on pourrait retourner au
stade Vélodrome retrouver
Timothée Timothée délaime est-ce que il
reste du monde sur place et est-ce que
les Marseillais continuent de célébrer
les les derniers instants de cette
présence du pape à Marseille
et bien Vincent pour la première
question non il reste plus grand monde
là dans le stade vous le voyez derrière
moi c'est tribune et qui se sont
complètement
vidés et place maintenant et bien au
service qui sont en train de de nettoyer
au service de nettoyage et puis
également le l'hôtel qui est en train
d'être démonté dès à présent donc voilà
tous les fidèles ont maintenant quitté
l'enceinte du stade nous-mêmes les
journalistes pour tout vous dire on
vient de m'indiquer qu'il fallait que je
parte d'ici 15 minutes grand maximum
voilà l'événement est terminé pour ce
qui se passe pour ce qui est du Stade
Vélodrome le programme reste encore
chargé à Marseille puisque il y a ce
soir une série de concerts qui ont été
annoncés à la à la fin de la messe tout
à l'heure et puis demain cette messe
également célébrée par le cardinal
l'archevêque de Marseille Monseigneur
Jean-Marc haveline qui cette messe qui
sera célébrée à la basilique Notre-Dame
de la Garde encore donc quelques
festivités ici à Marseille mais pour ce
qui est du stage Vélodrome la messe est
bien terminée les festivités aussi
merci beaucoup Timothée alors avant que
vous quittiez le stade Vélodrome vous
allez vous réinstaller à l'extérieur
comme ça peut-être que vous allez
pouvoir avoir encore des des fidèles
mais si on n'y arrive pas je vous pose
la question qu'est-ce qui vous a le plus
marqué au cours de ces de ces 48 heures
et bien ce qui m'a marqué Vincent en
tout cas pour ce qui est de cette messe
c'est vraiment et on l'a dit tout à
l'heure cette cette atmosphère cette
ambiance familiale puisqu'il y avait et
vous l'avez dit des jeunes mais ils sont
venus accompagner de leurs parents et
donc une ambiance voilà très familiale
une très bonne ambiance une ambiance
j'allais dire même chaleureuse on
sentait que les gens étaient vraiment
contents d'être là il y avait une
ambiance de fête cet après-midi à
Marseille et en tout cas au stade
Vélodrome on l'a dit également une
atmosphère très brillante avec beaucoup
de ferveur chez chez les fidèles on en a
vu beaucoup se mettre à genoux notamment
au moment de la consécration on a vu
certains se signer également au moment
de la communion donc voilà beaucoup de
monde beaucoup de familles et puis et
puis cette ferveur cette piété populaire
que l'on a senti également dans ces
différentes interviews que nous avons pu
que nous avons pu faire ici à l'antenne
donc voilà pour ce que je retiens en
tout cas de de cette journée de ces deux
jours ici passés par le pape par le pape
François pardon à Marseille le pape
François qui est en train d'arriver à
l'aéroport de Marignane dans sa fameuse
Fiat 500 qui a été quand même l'une des
révélations de ce voyage merci beaucoup
Timothée on vous retrouvera peut-être
après justement ces derniers instants de
cette visite que l'on est en train de
vivre en direct sur le site du Figaro
merci beaucoup de votre fidélité merci
beaucoup de votre présence à la fois sur
le site du Figaro et sur Youtube le pape
François donc qui
s'apprête à quitter le solde de France
en compagnie
accueilli être accueilli par Emmanuel et
Brigitte Macron qui sont arrivés juste
auparavant et qui se trouve avec lui
phénomène marquant peut-être un Philippe
Fontana c'est que Emmanuel Macron ne
rate pas un moment de mettre en scène la
proximité avec le Souverain Pontife mais
je l'espère pour les deux puisque
Emmanuel Macron il
c'est converti à 12 ans il a demandé le
baptême
on sent que le Président de la
République ne fait pas semblant et c'est
ça justement à quoi vous le sentez à sa
manière très proche de cette manière
d'être proche du Saint Père on peut on
peut c'est pas la touche Macron ça non
je crois pas je crois que le président
est quelqu'un qui qui est sincère sur sa
recherche de la foi qui est Madame
l'ambassadrice se connaît mieux que moi
et c'est touchant chacun avec chacun
avec son charisme
Giscard d'Estaing était très différent
quand avec le saint Paul 6 puisqu'on a
parlé de Paul 6 on a parlé de
l'influence de Jacques Maritain on a
parlé de l'influence de
comment s'appelle celui qui avait aussi
beaucoup d'influence le Guitton le
philosophe qui tombe on n'a pas parlé
George Pompidou parce que Georges la
relation entre Georges Pompidou et
catholicisme on ne la connais pas
on a parlé du général de Gaulle mais je
crois que il faut une très belle messe
d'obsèques à Saint-Louis-en-l'Île pour
exemple
le dernier site
à Rome je veux dire c'était quand le
président était allé à Rome c'était à
l'invitation du pape pour participer
aux journées sur la paix interreligieuse
organisée par saint-légiio dire
l'invitation c'est pas le président qui
s'était imposé
de la communauté des laïc qui est je
dirais un des vecteurs d'influence de du
pape c'est une c'est un groupe de laïc
qui a réussi à mettre en relation
plusieurs adversaires et à créer des
schémas de paix
ils sont très actifs qui ont joué un
rôle d'ailleurs dans le dans un retour
de dans un retour d'un groupe de
migrants également
il a une méthodologie qui s'appelle les
couloirs humanitaires qui qui donne lieu
je dirais à justement à une sélection
sur place à une préparation un
accompagnement et ensuite un placement
le tout si dans le cadre de la société
civile avec bien sûr la
l'accord des autorités et la France a
signé en 2017
sous le président Hollande un accord de
coopération avec sa légid-io la les
protestants c'est un il y a plusieurs la
Conférence des évêques des évêques de
France dire sur couloir humanitaire pour
les Syriens oui c'est comme la
réinstallation que que promeut la France
de de migrants qui sont des des vrais
exilés qu'on fait venir du Niger par
exemple parce qu'ils sont trop abîmés
par la vie et je voudrais rappeler la
la très bonne politique du gouvernement
qui malgré le fait qu'il ait été poussé
par des associations a choisi cinq
femmes afghane pour venir sur le
territoire national et une présence
d'université une chercheuse et ce sont
des femmes qui étaient en butte au
pouvoir Taliban et qui s'était déjà
réfugiés au Pakistan en fait ce qu'il
faut que les Français
parce qu'il faut que que les Français
comprennent c'est que l'État n'a plus la
main
sur la question de l'exil et sur la
question des demandeurs d'asile c'est
l'OFPRA qui certes à une administes et
c'est certain une administration oui et
non en fait c'est oui c'est une
administration mais qui décide de par
elle-même c'est-à-dire ce n'est pas
l'état qui décide ce sont des officiers
de protection c'est un établissement
administratif voilà je cherchais le mot
mais en fait l'état n'a pas la main
parce que l'OFPRA a une autonomie totale
dans son choix on voit d'un autre
départ
autour de du tapis rouge et et de la
de l'avion du pape entre les préfets de
la région sud et Sabrina agressi roubach
originaire de Marseille ministre
secrétaire d'État à la ville on a vu
également Benoît paillan et Gérald
Darmanin alors que les prélats et les
responsables ecclésiastiques
se rassemblent
avec une discussion également là
peut-être ça c'est les militaires de
l'Église de France on a vu vous avez
plusieurs dignes mais vous avez des
dignitaires de l'Église de France mais
vous avez aussi le cardinal membre Berti
qui est en train de discuter avec le
président de la conférence avec de
France le cardiaquement Bertier est un
cardinal français originaire de Corse
mais qui est le président de la
Signature apostolique qui est
l'équivalent de la Cour de cassation du
Saint-Siège on va dire ça comme ça les
canonismes pardonneront cette petite
imprécision et puis vous aviez ensuite
le nom s'apostolique et puis d'autres
d'autres
venezueliens qui sont sur les routes de
l'exil quand vous parliez de du défaut
d'influence du Saint Siège en Amérique
latine le gouvernement bolivarien a
généré au Venezuela avec le Nicolas avec
une politique très socialiste à jeter 7
millions de visuels sur les routes et le
Saint Siège a eu beaucoup de mal et à
beaucoup de mal à influer sur cette
crise il y a eu plusieurs médias sur
vénézuélienne il y a eu plusieurs
tentatives de médiation
pas uniquement du Saint Siège avec
d'autres avec les Suisses etc pourtant
ceux qui n'ont pas c'est un pays qui est
connu au plus haut niveau parce que le
canal Paoli
était ambassadeurs
le gardien LeBron qui était archevé de
Caracas Olivier des années 80 avait une
relation très étroite avec le Saint
Siège c'est un pays qui compte pour le
Saint Siège et sur lequel le Saint Siège
a beaucoup de mal à voir une influence
sur la sur la détermination de sa
politique c'est un pays qui a jeté sur
les routes des millions 7 millions voilà
des millions et c'est une des peuples
qui qui se plus sur le rôle de l'exil de
du monde entier
c'est intéressant le cas du Venezuela va
vous parler parce que c'est typiquement
la problématique auxquelles sont
confrontées un certain nombre de pays
avec ses départs massifs de population
du fait quand même de la politique des
gouvernements et aucun problème pour
lequel on vit d'accord ouvrir ses portes
pour la Colombie ça allait de soi parce
que quelque part en Amérique latine je
dis pas que c'est cette notion même la
notion de de de migrants clandestins
n'existe pas on dit in documenta sans
documental ce qui n'est pas péjoratif
sans papier mais il y a une fraternité
entre entre les peuples et de la même
engence que la fraternité entre la
France et les Ukrainiens on ne les voit
pas exactement et on sait et d'ailleurs
pourquoi pourquoi parce que on sait que
les Vénusiens un jour rentreront dans
leur pays on sait que les ukrainiens et
j'espère le plus vite possible
rentreront un jour dans leur pays encore
une fois ce n'est pas
sont des vrais demandeurs d'asile c'est
pas une ce sont pas des des exilés
économiques or l'exil économique ne va
pas forcément revenir dans son pays mais
quand même être les en l'exercice
différence entre migrants économique et
persécuté je pense que c'est pas une
règle absolue parce que moi qui ai vécu
en Haïti et je veux dire les un certain
de pays d'Amérique latine et notamment
le Chili a ouvert à une période donnée
sous un gouvernement de droite
sont
ses portes à l'Asie aux Haïtiens donc on
était dans deux des situations de du
départ économique c'était pas encore le
chaos avec les gangs qui avaient tout
pris et il vous avait eu je sais plus
disons 30 000 ne me reprenez pas sur les
chiffres parce que je ne les ai plus à
l'esprit mais ça a eu cette on a vu des
fils entières entières qui dormaient
plusieurs jours à l'aéroport pour
pouvoir aller au Chili donc le Chili
avait fait un geste d'ouverture on va
quitter l'Amérique latine au Brésil on
va quitter l'Amérique latine on va
revenir un petit peu en France
sur les questions que vous soulevez en
tout cas sont effectivement des cas
d'école
peut-être un petit peu une légende sous
la photo
qui voit-on là actuellement on a vu le
carnet à Laveline on voyait le cardinal
PARLINE aussi qui est le secrétaire
d'État on le présente souvent comme le
premier ministre du pape voilà les
choses sont un peu plus complexes mais
en tout cas secrétaire d'État qui
discute avec le cardinal Aveline
secrétaire d'État qui vient lui par
contre très souvent en France c'est un
invité régulier de Lourdes
pourquoi les choses sont un petit peu
plus complexes
parce que le côté de la nuance c'est la
limiteur
gouvernementale estatique et le
gouvernement du Saint Siège voilà et la
curé a été réduite dans ses pouvoirs par
le Saint Père bien sûr et notamment et
notamment la secrétaire
là aussi
père burger voudrait mettre de la nuance
non non mais tous les papes ont réformé
la curie pour qu'elle soit plutôt forgée
à leur manière donc oui aujourd'hui il y
a une forme de de perte de pouvoir au
sein de la Curie et puis voilà je veux
dire chaque pape chaque peuple la
façonne à sa manière donc
la dernière c'était 88 si les souvenirs
en l'appelant Montigny on pourrait
l'appeler bergolio sans sans
condescendance il a été élu pour ça il a
réussi
toute la thèse et tout le récit
passionnant du livre de Jean-Marie
gaynois qui l'avait déjà évoqué dans son
dans son premier livre jusqu'où ira
François c'était chez la tête à l'époque
et bien maintenant on sait jusqu'où il
est allé et c'est raconté et
admirablement bien raconté dans ce dans
ce livre et en particulier c'est très
forme de la curie qui avait été tenté
par ces prédécesseurs et je me souviens
Bernard Lecomte disait dans sa
biographie de Jean-Paul II c'est un
véritable serpent de mer et d'ailleurs
il y avait un bruit qui était
quand j'étais
auprès du Saint Siège avait ce bruit
mais vous verrez en fait il n'y a pas
besoin et il a déjà il a déjà fait des
pas ça n'arrivera pas ça ne se
concrétisera pas ça a été une rumeur
récurrente parmi les nombreuses rumeurs
vous souvenez que sous un Jean-Paul II
il y avait deux politiques différentes
par rapport au communisme il y avait
l'os politique
et de l'autre côté la politique
courageuse de Jean-Paul II on va
justement être y revenir peut-être que
ce serait une question sur l'islam
d'ailleurs
avec des anecdotes très intéressantes
d'ailleurs qui sont racontées sur ce sur
ce sujet là par Bernard Leconte ancien
de rédacteur en chef aux filières au
magazine et auteur d'une biographie de
référence sur sur Jean-Paul II et
effectivement qui raconte qu'elle a
prêté Jean-Paul II a imposé parfois
certaines décisions au sein de au sein
de l'Église en particulier dans ses
relations avec les pays de l'Est
notamment la Hongrie qu'il avait refusé
de visiter parce qu'il trouvait que le
carnet archevêque de Budapest était trop
calme collaborer trop avec le pouvoir
communiste notamment
la Caroline cardinal paroles peut-être
le cardinal haveline qui s'allume son
père
ce sont des moments où vous avez vécu ce
genre d'instant peut-être pas avec le
Pape François mais dans d'autres
occasions
est-ce que ce sont que des moments
formels et supersficiels ou bien il se
passe quand même dans ces instants là
quelque chose entre les personnes qui se
saluent ou on reste purement dans le
protocolaire tout dépend des personnes
c'est-à-dire c'est des fois le moment où
on glisse quelque chose etc où on se
promet de se revoir ou ça peut être
strictement protocolaire aussi là je
crois qu'il y a quand même lire cette
joie et cette chaleur je veux dire tout
le monde est content quand même et parce
que vous savez les membres de la curie
parfois sont peuvent être fermés là on
voit très bien que
vous avez une vous avez des anecdotes
qui vous reviennent sur ce des instants
un peu comparables
je vous ai parlé de
fallu quand le Premier ministre est venu
par exemple pour
en visite privée pour commémorer le
centenaire de la reprise des relations
diplomatiques c'était dans un cercle
restreint hors caméra et c'était comme
ça des discussions c'était très c'était
très très chaleureux chaleureux comme en
dire de plein pied très vite vous voyez
ce que je veux dire c'est à dire que le
protocole qui qu'on a l'impression de
lire évidemment dans les tenues avec les
élastiques tout ça celui-là il tombe
très facilement et comme je vous le
disais aussi je veux dire dans les
entretiens auxquels j'ai assisté
c'est-à-dire on assiste jamais à
l'entretien du Saint-Père avec le
président de la République c'est
toujours un huis clos mais par contre
avant le cardinal parlyn et le
Monseigneur Gallagher et le ministre
Jean-Yves Le Drian notamment
ça va très très vite on se salue on se
connaît bon alors l'Afrique qu'est-ce
que vous pensez de ceci qu'est-ce que
vous pensez de cela ah oui mais vous
dites allez hop on rentre dans une
discussion de partenaire peut-être un
commentaire on a vu le président de la
Conférence des évêques de France oui le
et Emmanuel Macron
échangé les relations
son cordiales mais il y a pu avoir quand
même des parfois des frictions notamment
au moment de du covid oui parce que
l'Église avait
l'Église de France mais pas que
d'ailleurs avec contesté certaines
décisions sanitaires qui étaient prises
notamment par rapport à l'évêque de Gap
sur notre antenne qui avait poussé une
colère
phénomène la présence des aumôniers dans
les prisons ou dans les hôpitaux qui
avaient été refusé pour des questions
sanitaires donc là dessus l'Église de
France a toujours
affiché son mécontentement dans
certaines situations mais les relations
sont cordiales et habituelles il faut il
faut quand même rappeler que l'Église de
France a des instances de dialogue et de
rencontres très régulières entre la
présidence de la République où
l'instance Matignon qui serait qui se
réunit deux ou trois fois par an de
mémoire pour pour gagner il y avait le
bureau des cultes au ministère de la
télé qui est l'interlocuteur naturel et
qui ne discute e et l'Église de France
j'allais dire à l'instar du pop François
ne fait pas uniquement prévaloir ses
propres prérogatives elle parle de tous
les sujets qui peuvent intéresser le
bien commun
et on termine par
Sabrina
et des cultes et des cultes et bureau
d'été sous la au sein du ministère de
l'Intérieur
disait que généralement les ministres
étaient ce genre de ministre était
soulagé quand justement le pape part
quelle responsabilité on en avait une
longue digression hier sur les questions
de sécurité quelle responsabilité vous
imaginez
justement Christophe corneven hier sur
cet Antoine entre la visite du roi
Charles III et la visite du Saint Père
et puis le tout tout le contexte
de la France
[Musique]
alors là par rapport à d'autres de
visites il y a pas eu de il n'y a pas eu
de discours il n'y a pas non plus
d'interprétation dim c'est assez c'est
assez sobre dans le on n'est pas sur le
protocole d'une visite d'État en tant
que tel et donc
vous voyez il y a des degrés dans les
visites protocolaires et donc là on
n'est pas sur une visite d'État et donc
c'est pour ça que les salutations ont
été faites j'allais dire en privé dans
une salle à l'aéroport et non pas public
avec discours de remerciement etc
[Musique]
il y a une garde il y a la présentation
drapeau etc etc
voilà
les derniers instants du pape François
qui va rentrer
normalement si ça s'est passé comme hier
par une porte latérale derrière l'avion
comme l'expliquait
Jean-Marie Guennois qui se trouve à
l'intérieur également de cet avion
Emmanuel Macron
station d'épouse assez dernier instant
les avions restent les avions ce genre
d'avion reste quand même aux armes du
Vatican
voilà les derniers derniers instants
donc de la présence du pape François à
Marignane alors que le Président de la
République donc
discute avec le cardinal d'archevêque de
Marseille qui aurait été l'homme avec le
Pape François de ces deux jours la
révélation pour certains et le maître
d'oeuvre incontestablement de ce voyage
qui donne toutes les impressions et tous
les signes de la réussite
le chef de l'État effectivement donc qui
doit encore passer quelques minutes ici
avant
que le pape ne reparte à Rome et ne
retourne à Rome
quelques éléments sur sur l'agenda du
pape dans les dans les prochains jours
ou bien c'est je suis pas dans le secret
des dieux
le grand dossier quand même qui va être
qui va revenir c'est ce que vous disiez
c'est quand même c'est l'ouverture du
sino de la semaine prochaine de le 3 ou
4 octobre de mémoire enfin en tout cas
c'est dans 8-10 jours donc là c'est
aussi les derniers préparatifs
évidemment ce
le Saint Siège va être agité par cette
actualité très forte il reçoivent quand
même plus de 350 personnes avec prêtres
et laïques du monde entier qui vont
venir pour cet instant pour ces trois
semaines intenses de débats de
discussions théologique éclésiologique
sur la gouvernance de l'église et sur
d'autres sujets donc ça va être un
moment très très fort il y aura des
discours très importants prévus du Saint
Père aussi notamment à l'ouverture du
Synode ou à la conclusion que l'on
attend
si notre préparé quand même depuis deux
ans
marche à fond depuis deux ans avec
toutes les parties du monde
remarquer que la secrétaire de du Synode
c'est une française c'est la sœur
Nathalie Becquart qu'on a vu
ce qui est le signe aussi d'une montée
en puissance
des femmes dans la gouvernance de
l'église aussi une entrée des femmes
dans la gouvernance de l'église monter
en puissance
il y a une volonté du Saint Père de que
les laïcs prennent plus de de part à la
gouvernance de l'église d'ailleurs la
réforme de la réforme de la curie qui
permet que des laïques soient mis
président de de dickester c'est-à-dire
l'équivalent de ministère pour l'instant
ça n'est pas
la communication la communication
le porte-parole de Jean-Paul II était
déjà laïque parole
c'était pas important il était pas dans
la position de gouvernants là le
dicaster pour la communication c'est
alors cette indicateur qui qui n'a quand
même pas tout à fait un pouvoir de
gouvernement en tant que tel
à la communication pas de l'avant parce
que le pape fait sa propre communication
ce qui va pas toujours
sans difficulté parce que
il n'a plus de porte-parole ce qui est
aussi est un problème c'est pourquoi
c'est un problème parce que il peut
surprendre par d'abord par le son choix
d'interview à qui à qui parle etc et
puis par parce qu'il va dire si vous
voulez mais il est quand même de ce
point de vue là largement incontrôlable
par
là en revanche avec la communication
sachant que par ailleurs il y a d'autres
instances qui font de la communication
est-ce que là aussi c'est un des
phénomènes de ce voyage on s'attendait
et notre traducteur d'ailleurs lui s'y
préparer à
des digressions et finalement la parole
a été quand même assez cadrée au cours
de oui ben le pape effectivement peut
être très libre par rapport au discours
qui sont préparés évidemment en amont
aux Journées Mondiales de la Jeunesse
cet été on a vu qu'il avait pris
beaucoup de distance avec les textes qui
lui étaient préparés ici il s'en est
tenu à son texte tout à l'heure pendant
le Méli il m'a semblé que parfois il
appuyait sur l'un ou l'autre mot en
relevant mais ils s'en est tenus au
texte je pense qu'il savait aussi que
entre s'adresser à des jeunes et
s'adresser dans dans une telle rencontre
aujourd'hui les enjeux évidemment il y a
des questions beaucoup plus équipe donc
voilà ils sont tenaient beaucoup plus à
ces textes salutations donc de Emmanuel
Macron pendant que vous parliez
un dernier mot peut-être une d'abord une
première question sur cette journée sur
cette messe d'abord que auquel nous
avons assisté que nous avons permis de
faire vivre aux internautes du Figaro
qu'est-ce qui vous aura le plus marqué
par Cédric moi c'est l'ambiance de
prière et les moments de silence qu'il y
a eu c'est à dire que il faut bien se
rendre compte que pour faire taire une
foule de 60000 personnes il faut il faut
autre chose qu'un appel au silence et
donc on voit bien que cette foule était
réunie dans une dans une communion de
prière et d'écoute extrêmement forte
d'ailleurs le pape François il faut le
noter dans tous les rassemblements est
extrêmement écoutée dans ces paroles
parce que aussi il a il a il a un
langage qui est extrêmement simple et
accessible et donc ces homélies sont
toujours un impact fort sur la foule et
moi je trouve que ça donnait une très
belle image de célébration on n'était
pas simplement là pour un moment festif
mais pour prier ensemble on va retrouver
Timothée délai dans un instant à
Marseille où il y a encore des fidèles
maintenant autour de du stade qui ont
assisté à cette messe sur cette messe
sur cette séquence qu'est-ce qui vous a
le plus marqué
j'ai vécu de ça l'ensemble comme une
espèce de la messe on verra pour
l'ensemble après un moment de communion
je veux dire un espèce de moment de
grâce d'apaisement
dans ce bois
vraiment d'apaisement et
de proximité
Philippe Fontana il m'a semblé que ça
vous a un peu touché cette messe et ses
instants ces moments est-ce que je me
trompe non faut tromper pas on en
revient à la mission primaire de
l'église de dispenser des sacrements
pour pour le catholique c'est quand même
plus qu'un moment de grâce c'est la
transsubs sensation
préciser ce dont
le par les paroles c'est le prêtre une
personne âme Christie donc dans la
personne écrit Christ avec les paroles
du Christ le pain se transforme dans le
corps du Christ vous croyez à ça vous
êtes bouleversé et c'est cette vraie
séparation entre toutes les autres
religions nous avons la chance que le
Christ soit mort pour nos péchés et qui
est ce renouvellement non sanglant de la
Passion du Christ qui se manifeste tous
les jours par la multitude de sacrifices
propice à tarte de chacun des prêtres
c'est pour ça que tu es prête ne sont
pas des gens comme des autres et c'est
pour ça qu'on doit leur donner une
certaine révérence parce qu'ils ont ce
pouvoir de de faire revenir le Christ
dans notre vie et pas seulement
spirituellement c'est quelque chose qui
est moi qui m'aimais personnellement
dans la région catholique et c'est cette
émotion vous avez ressenti exactement
on va assister à ces derniers instants
et
rejoindre dans un instant Timothée délai
mais après peut-être le
départ de cet avion
la SkyTeam dans lequel se trouve le pape
le pape François vous avez vous n'avez
jamais assisté à des voyages avec le
Pape ah non
je suis pas journaliste
[Rires]
le
dernier mot beaucoup dans le livre de
Jean-Marie gaynouard il insiste beaucoup
sur la sur la sur la culture du enfin en
tout cas la culture du secret au Vatican
est-ce que c'est quelque chose que vous
avez vous avez ressenti pas la culture
du secret de la discrétion dire bon
si vous pensez que vous allez
au Vatican etc pour aujourd'hui
j'entends pouvoir récupérer des
indiscrétions etc je pense qu'on se
trompe totalement et aujourd'hui sans
doute beaucoup plus qu'hier parce que la
Curie est un peu tétanisé aussi un par
un pape effectivement
autoritaire et que par conséquent
on reste dans dans on est plus du tout
dans le registre où les éclairsastiques
sortaient en ville allez dîner
du terrain avait une vie mondaine je
crois que enfin moi ça ça n'existe plus
je veux dire on peut aller chez des amis
tout ça mais en grand en discrétion mais
c'est repas si vous voulez ou
autour d'un ecclésiastique qui
voilà était au centre de l'attention en
tout cas dans le avec le corps
diplomatique ça n'existe plus pas on a
des déjeuners de travail on peut avoir
des dîners de travail on a des dînés
thématiques pour à l'occasion d'une
visite ou d'un sujet bah la visite des
évêques de France etc si vous voulez
mais on n'est pas du tout je dirais dans
comment on dit cette courbe vaticale qui
brillent de de cette ambiance faisante à
la curie après la reprise en main
justement par le pape François vous
l'avez senti
un ambassadeur si vous parlez à un
rédacteur la plupart du temps il va pas
vous répondre il va vous dire en gros
mais même l'ambassadrice demandé au
préfet je dirais ils vous renvoie
l'échelon hiérarchique supérieur il faut
avoir noué des relations de sympathie
etc pour vous avez réussi à avoir des
confidences des confidences non non non
je ne pense pas avoir des confidences
c'est à dire je suis pas sûr d'être allé
en chercher parce que bon ce qui
alimente pardonnez-moi aussi beaucoup la
presse vaticanisme etc c'est entre
guillemets des confidences peut-être des
rats alors les Italiens évidemment on
est à Rome ça participe ça participe un
peu de
du climat du climat général mais bon on
a glosé à l'infini sur le fait que le
pape allait démissionner si vous ne
croyez pas du tout
je pense que si le démissionne c'est le
jour où il perdra c'est ses facultés moi
qui sentira qui perd ses facultés
mentales
si c'est le cas le l'avion justement en
tous les cas il a montré qu'il ne les
avait pas du tout perdu au cours de ce
voyage
nous voyons actuellement l'avion en
train de quitter l'aéroport de Marignane
dans un instant on va retrouver Timothée
délai qui est à Marseille avec avec un
prêtre du diocèse enfin peut-être du
diocèse de Marseille ça il va nous le
dire j'ai pas encore la précision
dernier instant de cette présence du
pape François ici
sous les contreforts de la
Sainte-Victoire on est entre Marseille
et Aix-en-Provence sous le soleil sous
le soleil et ça a été aussi peut-être
l'un des éléments majeurs ces images
magnifiques de la de la cité phocéenne
qui reste je sais pas si c'est votre
votre avis mais on peut dire ce qu'on
veut de Marseille mais c'est caresses
quand même un site extraordinaire et
peut-être c'est l'une des expressions
qu'on retiendra Marseille est un sourire
sur la carte c'est très joli ça
il y avait pas pensé mais en tous les
cas c'est une ville qui qui est beaucoup
aimée de ces de ses habitants et qui est
c'est vrai que ça c'est une spécificité
assez marseillaise quand même il y a une
il y a un attachement très fort du
Marseillais à sa cité
il y a un phénomène qu'on ne voit plus
d'ailleurs qu'on n'a pas vu mais enfin
Benoît XVI avait rompu avec ça c'était
le phénomène qui avait initié Jean-Paul
II qui était celui d'embrasser le sol
d'un pays quand tu l'aborder pour la
première fois
Benoît XV ne l'avait pas fait de mémoire
non plus mais est-ce que c'est pas
Jean-Paul II justement qui a été le pape
qui a initié justement ce genre de
était vous ne parlez l'expression
Jean-Paul II était un homme de théâtre
et donc il avait mis en place comme ça
une certaine gestuelle qui qui lui
permettait d'être
reconnu vu qu'il lui était propre aussi
donc chaque pas passé à ses habitudes et
c'est c'est traditions voilà Benoît XVI
on voit bien qu'il avait une sorte de
réserve
très très humble et très timide voilà on
a des papes qui sont très différents
on a assisté justement et on les a vécus
ici en direct ces obsèques est-ce qu'il
y a une nostalgie venant à 16 encore au
Vatican oui
oui bien sûr bien sûr ça fait partie je
dirais des des
divisions je veux dire bon vous avez
cité vers le cardinal Sarah quand on est
vraiment
l'illustration par exemple
l'obéissance au pape reste quand même la
ligne de la ligne super mais suprême
mais enfin oui il y a bien sûr qu'il y a
eu des tensions bien sûr et puis
d'autant plus que dire quand même c'est
le premier pape
qui a un pontificat avec un pape émérite
ça n'a jamais existé dire donc ça aussi
c'est une spécificité
il y a pas de statut pour ne pas payer
vite
et il y a eu cette cohabitation alors
évidemment alors voilà parmi les ragots
alors à la maison tente ceci voilà
effectivement que l'ancien secrétaire du
pape François en tous les cas du pape
Benoît XVI avait quelques avec quelques
points à reprocher au successeur de
Benoît XV et qu'il a été quand même on
va pas rentrer dans les détails mais
il y avait aussi de sa part quelques
sorties de route ou imprudence disons
des imprudences qui a commencé par
écrire un livre
on va pas rentrer dans les détails parce
que c'est compliqué mais oui il y a eu
ce livre ou
qui est sorti je veux dire en
avec
une présentation qui était quand même
qui était quand même biaisée qui donnait
à penser que c'était il y avait il avait
été effectivement
validé si je puis dire voir co-écrit
avec Benoît ça fait Benoît XVI
il y a eu pas entrer
en tout état de cause si vous voulez
tout ça a créé évidemment je veux dire
des à créer des problèmes alors il y a
un problème c'est toute la c'est l'une
des difficultés
d'avoir eu un pape émérite alors je
respecte évidemment la décision de
Benoît XVI en fait quand vous avez un
pape émérite vous avez des visiteurs
j'allais dire un peu comme on dit pour
le pouvoir politique vous avez les
visiteurs du soir et qui ensuite comment
en ville ce qu'ils auraient soi-disant
entendu dans ses visites n'oubliez pas
qu'il y a une très forte
instrumentalisation
moi j'aime quand je suis arrivé je me
rappelle de Monsieur Salvini en short
sur les plages avec son grand son
t-shirt là pendu mon pape c'est Benoît
et puis voilà les pieds dans l'eau avec
le chapelet normalement comme ils
étaient très différents sur certains
aspects notamment liturgiques ou autre
évidemment les différents courants de
l'église se saisissent qui de Benoît XVI
de François et voilà mais
mais ça ne renvoie à la à l'évangile du
jour qui n'a pas été celle de la messe
c'est sur la sur le semeur et on
reconnaît aussi l'arbre à ses fruits
toujours pareil et qui remplit les
églises et qu'il est vide ça c'est un
autre un autre débat et alors que on
voit donc l'avion du pape François
quitté cette fois-ci pour de bons le sol
le sol français on va essayer de
retrouver Timothée délaime à Marseille
qui est avec un des un prêtre qui a
assisté Timothée est-ce que vous êtes
toujours avec le prêtre et
justement c'est à vous c'est vous qui
avez la parole
oui Vincent voilà nous sommes avec avec
un prêtre un prêtre du diocèse
d'Aix-en-Provence formateur au séminaire
c'est quelque part l'avenir de l'Église
de France que vous avez amené
aujourd'hui à cette messe du pape
François oui en effet avec plus d'une
trentaine de séminaristes qui sont issus
de différentes de la région notamment
Marseille et Aix et Arles nous sommes
venus donc hier à Notre-Dame de la Garde
prier avec le Pape et puis aujourd'hui
pour la célébration donc de
l'Eucharistie et vous faites partie
effectivement vous me le disiez de ces
privilégiés qui ont pu assister à cette
prière hier à notre âme de la garde dans
une dans une atmosphère on imagine là
aussi assez brillante vu que vous
n'étiez pas très nombreux comment est-ce
que vous avez vécu ce moment là
personnellement je l'ai vécu j'ai trouvé
que c'était simple et profond et je
pense aussi que même pour les scénariste
et les personnes qui étaient là
à travers les mots de la viande de ce
qu'a dit le Pape François sur sur le
fait d'une une vraie compassion et d'une
d'une tendresse il a parlé même de d'une
caresse spirituelle que nous avons à
avoir
les uns envers les autres et notamment
les plus défavorisés les migrants on
sentait quelque chose à l'image de la
Bonne Mère de très maternel et je pense
que il y a une dimension comme ça
maternelle à la fois de la Vierge Marie
mais de l'Église qui est apparue dans
dans ce temps de prière qui était
d'ailleurs dédié à la Vierge Marie
qu'est-ce que vous retiendrez plus
généralement de ces deux jours passés
par le pape François à Marseille
je je pense que c'est en tout cas un
très grand encouragement pour vraiment
des milliers de personnes notamment par
rapport à ceux qui se passe à Marseille
avec une ville qui est vraiment
cosmopolite avec qui croise les cultures
les religions et qui depuis de très très
nombreuses années à l'habitude du
dialogue et je pense que c'est un
véritable encouragement face aux
difficultés de la vie du monde de la
société aussi
à poursuivre ce dialogue un véritable
dialogue d'amitié tel qu'il a toujours
été vécu à Marseille et tel qu'il
devient je pense aussi emblématique par
pour les enjeux en tout cas de si ce
n'est du monde de la Méditerranée
j'entendais l'un de vos confrères tout à
l'heure dire que cette cette visite du
pape François à Marseille elle est
portée des fruits est-ce que c'est une
analyse que vous partagez et de quelle
manière cette visite portera-t-elle des
fruits selon vous
je pense que le fait que le pape soit
venu à Marseille et que
c'est aussi Marseille est un symbole
fort aussi pour la France c'est je pense
ça peut porter du fruit pour l'Église
qui traverse notamment l'église de
France qui qui traverse de vrais
difficultés
on le sait par ailleurs donc c'est quand
on voit comment j'allais dire le Pape a
été accueilli et comment on s'est senti
proche de lui parce qu'il était proche
de nous comme il le prêche d'ailleurs
souvent
nous je pense que ça c'est c'est un
véritable fruit d'espérance et notamment
je pense pour des séminaristes donc des
futurs prêtres une véritable Javier
espérance qui qui peut renaître et une
véritable confiance dans l'avenir comme
dans l'humanité et dans l'église aussi
vous parlez des séminaristes que vous
côtoyez et quotidiennement vu que vous
êtes formateur au Sém qu'est-ce que la
figure du pape François leur inspire et
bien c'est c'est une figure pour eux qui
qui est une figure qui bouscule parce
que il pose des questions et et des
questions j'allais dire qui qui nous qui
oblige les jeunes à vraiment faire face
à la réalité et à ne pas avoir fait
avoir peur de de faire face à cette
réalité et je pense que c'est c'est un
homme qui qui du coup peut vraiment
invité les jeunes en général mais les
les séminaristes les futurs prêtres en
particulier a aussi à se poser non
seulement pour eux-mêmes mais pour ceux
dont ils auront la charge les véritables
et les bonnes questions est-ce que vous
pensez qu'il y a ou qu'il y a pu avoir à
certains moments une forme
d'incompréhension entre le la communauté
catholique française et le Saint-Père
forcément il y a des points de
d'accroche parce que il y a des sujets
sensibles l'immigration est un sujet
sensible la liturgie est un sujet
sensible donc c'est sûr que c'est il y a
pu avoir
parfois une
interrogation en tout cas de la part de
certains chrétiens sur qu'est-ce qu'il
fallait penser exactement et est-ce que
jusqu'où on pouvait aller
dans la manière d'avancer de de
réfléchir et peut-être d'une certaine
remise en question sur des sur des sur
ce que l'on croyait totalement acquis et
qu'il ne l'est pas vraiment merci
beaucoup voilà Vincent pour ce
témoignage donc de ce prêtre du diocèse
d'Aix-en-Provence alors que je vous le
disais le stade c'est totalement vidé le
parvis également sur lequel il est resté
tout à l'heure quelques quelques
personnes en train de discuter c'est
vider également c'est le signe que cette
cet événement est bel et bien terminé
merci beaucoup Timothée merci à vous et
effectivement on voit encore l'avion du
pape François qui s'est quitté continuer
de quitter le tarmac de l'aéroport ainsi
que celui d'Emmanuel Macron qui lui
revient à Paris merci beaucoup à
ce prêtre du diocèse d'Aix-en-Provence
on salue bien sûr tout les internautes
de d'Aix-en-Provence de la région
d'Aix-en-Provence et de Marseille
et de ces de ces magnifiques régions
françaises merci de leur fidélité merci
de continuer à nous suivre surtout les
internautes niçoise qu'il y en a
beaucoup et vous pouvez recevoir
d'ailleurs le Figaro dans ces régions
non seulement bien sûr toujours en
direct sur YouTube comme c'est le cas
actuellement sur le site mais également
à la radio avec Figaro radio
admirablement géré par notre concert
autres CRS l'immigration la liturgie
sont deux sujets sensibles est-ce que
c'est pas ça aussi en creux ce qui va
peut-être ressortir de ce de ce voyage
en tous les cas bon sur sur
l'immigration et est-ce qu'il peut pas y
avoir
je pose la question un dialogue sur ces
questions là
à l'intérieur de à l'intérieur des
communautés chrétiennes catholiques et
même au sein des institutions et de
l'élastiques perso en tout cas un voyage
comme celui-là avec des paroles aussi
fortes que nous avons entendues ne
laissera pas ni la communauté catholique
ni j'allais dire la société française
indifférente on voit bien que
l'Église dans ces deux jours
a eu une parole
lumineuse alors on sera d'accord ou pas
d'accord mais en tout cas une parole
pour reprendre l'expression
éclairer les consciences et de la même
manière que quand on est éclairé dans sa
conscience ensuite on a chacun un choix
à faire à se déterminer par rapport à
cette lumière nouvelle qui a été posée
et donc je suis la question c'est de
savoir s'il faut choisir la voie qui est
suggéré par celui qui éclaire la
conscience ou bien selon sa conscience
mais en suivre une mais de toute façon
déjà je trouve que on n'est pas tous
face à des situations de migration mais
comme la rappeler le pape François de
manière très forte et très belle dans
son homélie on est tous face à des
situations de fragilité quelle qu'elle
soit c'est quelqu'un en bas de chez soi
c'est son voisin de palier etc et en
fait au fond le grand message qui a été
redéployé pendant ces deux jours c'est
comment est-ce qu'on se situe par
rapport à cette pauvreté que je vois
sous mes yeux on a évoqué tout à l'heure
la parabole du bon Samaritain dans
l'Évangile c'est exactement cela vous
êtes sur le chemin et il y a un pauvre
sur le chemin vous vous détournez le
regard où vous vous en occupez en
descendant de votre monture et bien le
pape François nous appelle chacun à une
forme de responsabilité et comme je le
disais tout à l'heure
au soir de cette vie on sera jugé sur
l'amour et bien moi comme prêtre je
rappelle souvent mes paroissiens où je
me le séminariste où je me le rappelle à
moi-même c'est au soir de cette vie
quand j'aurai en présenter devant le
jugement de Dieu Dieu demandera des
comptes sur la pauvreté que j'ai croisé
dans ma vie et là qu'est-ce que je
répondrais et bien je trouve que le pape
François a sa manière nous a
réinterpellé de manière très vive sur
cette question que Dieu finira par nous
poser d'une manière ou d'une autre qui
que nous soyons et de quelques religions
que nous soyons deux dernières questions
rapides on a évoqué on a invoqué une
figure c'est celle de Charles de
Foucauld tête d'un mot de qu'il
s'agit-il Charles de Foucauld était un
homme qui s'est converti de manière
assez radicale aux catholicisme qui a
fait une expérience de Dieu très forte
dans sa vie et qui est ensuite partie
vivre dans une forme de désert il a une
spiritualité très très liée à la
spiritualité du désert mais en même
temps dans le dialogue et Charles de
Foucauld et et marquée par une forme de
fraternité universelle aussi et donc il
nous rappelle ce message de l'église et
du christianisme d'abord qui nous
rappelle que chaque homme et chaque
femme on est d'abord frères et soeur
avant d'être citoyen ou différents par
l'ethnie la race où je ne sais quoi
dernière question l'avion a quitte les
airs
s'envolent en tous les cas dans les airs
il est dans les airs encore
un secteur français ça va pas durer
longtemps qu'est-ce que vous retenez de
ce voyage qu'est-ce que vous retenez de
ces 48 heures
quoi qu'on en dise et là je ça serait
plutôt une parole un peu politique quoi
qu'on en dise la parole de l'Église
n'est pas faite pour rester enfermée
dans les sacristies et qu'elle est
encore attendu de Parlement c'est ce
qu'en tout cas ce que vous avez fait on
vous en remercie merci beaucoup merci
Cédric burghin
Elisabeth le temps d'aller avec vous
avez passé ce marathon avec nous on vous
en remercie d'ailleurs qu'est-ce qui
vous a le plus marqué et quel est
l'instant qui nous aura le plus marqué
ah je pense que c'est la messe je pense
que c'est la messe pourquoi
parce que
ce silence effectivement et cette
communion de de jeunes de moins jeunes
croyant ou pas croyant je ne suis pas
sûr qu'il n'y avait que un peuple de
catholique et comme je dis pour moi j'ai
ce ressenti ça je dirais comme une je
répète comme une espèce de respiration
une respiration qui qui vous porte si
vous voulez qui vous fait effectivement
je dis recadrer recadrer les choses dans
dans et sortir si je puis dire de
comment dire d'approche strictement
Franco franco-française politique ou
politicienne ou etc voilà c'est aussi ça
une réalité je veux dire cette France
dont on dit qu'elle va si mal qu'elle
est fracturée qu'elle est ceci cela elle
sait comme ça se retrouver pendant un
moment alors un moment de grâce ou un
moment
profondément où on vit profondément sa
religion
en toute état de cause ça a eu lieu ça a
eu lieu donc moi je dis merci pape
François aussi et que chacun aussi fait
dire dans ce message qui bouscule les
consciences je le répète il sait aussi
le message d'un homme qui
regarde qui a un message universel et
qui regarde le monde dans sa globalité
le pessimisme je crains que le pape
n'est réussi à parler qu'à une fraction
de la population le pape dénonça juste
titre la création de ghetto entre nous
et c'est ce qui est en train d'arriver
en France je crains que sans réel
apostolat envers les autres envers les
migrants envers nos frères dans l'islam
le message du pape soit de plus en plus
tarié je le crains je suis très
pessimiste demain c'est place à l'action
des états pour contenir les migrants non
pas l'arrivée en Europe mais au départ
des côtes méditerranéennes tant qu'on y
arrivera pas et il y aura encore des
morts en Méditerranée et je ne veux pas
et que la Méditerranée devienne
assimilière donc voyez j'ai d'un côté un
message pessimiste et de l'autre côté
j'ai un message réaliste mais qui va
totalement rebours de celui du pape
en tout cas on peut citer bernados quand
on vous écoute parce que je disais les
optimistes n'ont pas pitié des hommes ce
qui n'est pas absolument pas votre cas
mon cher Philippe Fontana merci beaucoup
de nous avoir suivi merci d'avoir été en
direct Jean-Marie gaynouard Le Pape
François la révolution on vous
recommande encore ce livre effectivement
c'est un plaidoyer pour notre paroisse
vous nous en voudrez pas mais quand
effectivement l'oeuvre est bonne il faut
absolument la lire et c'est même un
chef-d'oeuvre de la part de Jean-Marie
gesoin c'est un livre important qu'il
faut lire et qui reviendra certaine sur
certaines idées reçues et d'ailleurs sur
la réputation qu'on fait parfois un
autre confrère d'opposants au pape et
bien vous lirez comme d'habitude comme
souvent comme c'est le cas ici sur
Figaro live ou la ligne éditoriale c'est
d'abord celle de la nuance et bien que
c'est beaucoup plus nuancé que cela est
effectivement
l'honneur du journalisme c'est de dire
les choses telles qu'elles sont et non
pas telles qu'on voudrait qu'elle soit
merci beaucoup de nous avoir suivis
merci beaucoup d'avoir
vécu ces instants qui étaient quoi qu'on
en pense un constat incontestablement
très fort très intense comme le disait
précisément Jean-Marie Guennois tout à
l'heure merci aux équipes merci à vous
d'être venu merci à vous en particulier
Elisabeth le temps délègue d'avoir été
le fil rouge tout au long de ces de ces
de ses heures et merci à Xavier
DRIANCOURT et à Matteo gisalberti
d'avoir été avec nous à Arthur Verda
Jean-Marie guesnoy sur place et bien sûr
à notre excellent confrère Timothée
d'elle merci aux équipes mobilisées en
régie Sacha Baudry les asafrani Damien
Perpignan Victor Griset Nicolas bichon à
la traduction François divas lo son
Germain et Fidan et Riad Becker à la
réalisation et un Isaac à la provocation
Guillaume carace Elias prefad qui font
justement
qui sont en train de découper ces
extraits que vous allez pouvoir
redécouvrir sur le site du Figaro le
replay de cette messe et de ce live sur
le compte Youtube du Figaro merci
également à c'est une varie au réseau
qui a qui s'est chargé de la modération
et parfois il y avait un peu de travail
à faire et à Gilles Boutin à la
rédaction en chef du site du Figaro
merci beaucoup merci de nous avoir suivi
et on se retrouve très vite prochain
live sur le site du Figaro demain soir
dimanche pour les résultats aux
élections sénatoriales là il va partir
de 20h avec Thibault Gauthier et
Emmanuel galliero je vous retrouve pour
ma part en direct sur le site du Figaro
lundi soir pour un nouveau numéro de
point de vue rendez-vous à partir de 17h
mais vous restez avec nous parce que il
y a toujours des infos des vidéos c'est
sur Le Figaro